Hey everybody, I have an exciting duo episode of about a topic that a lot of people have been talking about. You really can't go on. Well, depending, I guess I can't go on social media without seeing stuff about chat GPT everywhere on every app all over the place. Oh, OK. I shouldn't fess up that. No, I'm just kidding. I've heard of it. Yes. Yeah. ChatGBD is totally blowing up. Have you tried it? I have not. Okay. Yeah. It's pretty wild. I would highly recommend it. But yeah, we're going to dive really deep into that, but we're going to do a full duo episode, which is really exciting. I think that one thing I started to do a little bit of inside baseball here but you know we have an
大家好，这一期节目我们两人要聊一个大家都在讨论的话题。真的没法继续……好吧，看情况，我觉得我如果不刷社交媒体，到处都能看到关于ChatGPT的内容，每个应用上都是。哦，好吧。我不该承认这一点。不，我开玩笑的。我听说过它。是的。没错，ChatGPT彻底火了。你试过吗？我还没试过。好吧。是的，它真的很疯狂。我强烈推荐你试试。但没错，我们要深入探讨一下，而且我们要录制一期完整的双人节目，这真的很令人兴奋。我觉得我开始做一点“内幕”分享了，你知道我们有一个
intake form where um you know we talk to some folks if it looks like that it will be great content for you all um well we provide a link and people can fill out the intake form and we've had a ton of really exciting opportunities to interview people from all over the world about amazing stuff. But it means that, you know, if we do that, then there's no room for duo episodes. So I started filling out the intake form myself. So we'll notice that some of the times we go to record, it's actually an interview with with us so i think a great opportunity for us you know the two of us to just uh hang out chat about a cool topic that's uh that's pretty relevant and can't get much more relevant than that so you teed it up very well all right so we'll do as an intro topic you know i um i refloored my attic so what that means is is the attic has a bit of sort of ways of how
入驻表格，嗯，你知道我们会和一些人交谈，如果看起来这对大家来说会是很棒的内容，嗯，我们会提供一个链接，人们可以填写这个入驻表格。我们已经有了很多非常令人兴奋的机会，可以采访来自世界各地的人，聊聊很棒的事情。但这意味着，你知道，如果我们那样做，就没有空间录制双人节目了。所以我开始自己填写这个入驻表格。所以你会注意到，有时我们去录音时，其实是我们两个人的采访。所以我认为这是一个很好的机会，让我们两个人聚在一起，聊聊一个很酷且非常相关的话题，没有什么比这更相关的了。你开场开得很好。好吧，那我们先做一个开场话题。你知道，我重新铺设了阁楼的地板，这意味着阁楼有一些……关于你的房子或这些木框架房屋是如何建造的。你有一堆像这样粗大的木梁，这是车库上方的阁楼，所以我们有这些木梁。如果你在阁楼上，木梁下面是，我想，车库天花板的材质，我想是干墙或石膏板之类的东西。但它非常容易损坏。如果你试着走在上面，你会直接掉下去，最后掉进车库里。所以把东西放在那里并不实用。所以我最后买了一堆胶合板，把它们铺好，这样我就可以在上面走动了。所以，你知道，因为这个，
of how your house or these wood frame houses are constructed you have a bunch of these giant like thick wooden beams this is the attic over over the garage so so we have these wooden beams if you're up in the attic and then below the wooden beams is, I guess, whatever the ceiling of the garage is made out of, which is, I guess, like drywall or sheetrock or something, something like that. But it's something that's like really easily breakable. Like if you were to try to walk on it, you would just go right through and you would end up in your garage. And so it's not really practical to put things there. So I ended up getting just a bunch of plywood and putting plywood down so I could walk around and all that. And so, you know, because of that,
我需要拧入大量的螺丝，而且我想做好，因为这是直接拧进房子里的。很难重做。我在亚马逊上发现了这个东西，它看起来像一块砖头。帕特里克，你可能有一百万个这种东西，你会觉得我真的很笨，你比我更擅长动手。但它看起来有点像砖头，上面有一堆不同大小的孔。它的想法是，你知道，你把钻头插进去……这块砖抵住你想钻孔的地方，然后你把钻头穿过砖头。然后砖头就起到了导向的作用。哦，你说的是钻孔导向器。
I needed to screw in a ton of screws and I wanted to do a good job because it's screwing right into the house. It's kind of hard to do a do over. And I found this thing on amazon it's basically it looks like a brick and patrick you probably have like a million of these you're gonna think i'm really done with this you're much more handy than i am but it looks kind of like a brick and it's got a bunch of holes of different sizes and the idea is you know you stick the drill like this brick goes up against whatever wherever you want to drill the hole and then you stick the drill through the brick. And then just because the brick acts like a guide. Oh, you're talking about a drill guide.
对，对。是的，当你钻孔时，它会保持90度角。是的，我的意思是，这是最简单的东西。在亚马逊上只要5美元左右。这真的让我思考，还有多少像这样我不知道的简单东西？我以为你会说你买了一把螺丝枪，就是那种自动上料的进料器，你只需要……就像钉枪一样把螺丝打进去，但那是针对螺丝的。是的，你知道，我见过那个，我们重新装修了露台。当我们买
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, and then when you drill the hole, it goes at a 90-degree angle. Yeah, I mean, this is the simplest thing. It was like $5 on Amazon. And it really made me think, how many simple things are there like this that I don't know about? I thought you were gonna say you bought a screw gun, which is the like auto loading feeder where you just and you just like drive the screws like a nail gun, but for screws. Yeah, you know, I've seen that we had our deck redone. When we bought
房子的时候，露台都烂了。所以我们不得不重做。在这种情况下，我们付钱请人来做。他们就有那种工具。而且他们用的那种很长，大概有四英尺长。所以他们可以走着走着就把螺丝打进去。不过，想到你我就觉得无比开心。我知道可能不是那样。我只是在想四英尺乘八英尺的胶合板平衡在你的肩膀上，你知道，穿过阁楼入口，然后翻过去钻孔。是的，好吧，其实我还有另一个很酷的购买，
the house, the deck was all rotted. And so we had to redo it. In this case, we paid somebody to do it. And they had one of those. And they actually had one where they could, it was long, like super, like four feet long or something. And so they could just walk and just as they're walking, put the screws in. I'm getting no end of joy, though, of thinking about you. I know probably wasn't. I'm just thinking of four foot by eight foot plywood sheets like balanced on your shoulders you know like going up through the attic injury and like over and drilling them yeah like well actually i have another cool purchase
既然你提到了。我买了四英尺乘八英尺的胶合板，这是标准尺寸，但我没法把它放进阁楼，因为考虑到梯子和所有东西。所以我不得不把它切开……阁楼很高，所以八英尺的部分没问题，只是需要窄一点。所以我不得不把它切成两英尺乘八英尺的部分。再说一次，我的手一点也不稳，我不是个好艺术家，你知道，比如手绘什么的。我的手最不稳了。所以我发现了一个东西，你可以把锯子拧在上面，它就像一个导向器。
now that you mention it so i had i bought the four foot by eight foot plywood which is the sort of standard size but i can't i couldn't fit that into the attic because when you take the ladder and everything into account so i had to cut it into the attic's really tall so the eight foot part was fine it just needed to be narrow so i had to cut it into two feet by eight foot sections and again like i do not have a steady hand at all like i'm not a good artist uh you know like with hand drawing and i. I like the least steady hand. So I found this thing where you screw your saw into it, and it acts like a guide.
你可以选择你想要多厚的木板。然后它沿着胶合板的边缘运行，这样你就不会弄坏它。别去查“轨道锯”这个词，你会为了做这种板材切割而买一堆工具。是的，哦，是的。但即使是那个导向器，你知道，因为我知道他们制造台锯之类的东西，非常贵。这个导向器也只要15到20美元，就是个塑料玩意儿。而且，是的，切割出来的线条非常完美。所以，是的，这让我意识到，你知道，有一些简单的基于几何原理的东西，可能是古罗马人用的，或者类似的东西，它们非常便宜且非常有效。好吧，好吧，我会做……你剧透了你要把这个作为话题。
And you choose how many inches thick you want the thing to be. And then it runs along the side of the plywood so that you can't mess it up. Don't go looking up the words track saw you'll end up with no end of tools for doing this sheet wood breakdown yes oh yeah but even that guide you know because i know they make table saws and things like that they're super expensive this guide was also like maybe 15 20 bucks just plastic thing and uh yeah the lines the the cuts came out perfect so yeah it just it made me realize like you know there's simple geometric geometry based things that probably the ancient romans used or something that are really cheap and really effective well okay i'll do so you you spoiled that you were going to do this as a topic.
所以我试着准备了一些东西。关于木工的话题，我要说，没有什么比用日本拉锯（Dozuki）锯木头更让我快乐的了。什么？如果你只用过西式锯，比如在你的……好吧，如果你来自欧洲或美国，我想，
And so I tried to prepare something. So on the topic of woodworking, I will say that I get no more pleasure than sawing using a Japanese pool saw, a Suzuki. What? If you've only ever used Western style, like in your... Okay, if you come from Europe or America, I guess,
而且你习惯了推锯，那种在推的过程中切割的锯子，比如劳氏（Lowe's）卖的那种廉价建筑锯。那些东西太糟糕了。它们是垃圾。如果你只是想分解2x4木料或类似的东西，它们很难用。但如果你试着做杰森说的那种事，就非常困难。相反，给自己买一把非常便宜的Dozuki，也就是拉锯。它其实非常薄且灵活，所以你不能推它。所以它只在拉的时候受力，利用钢材的张力来切割。这更符合人体工程学。
and you're used to a push saw, which cuts on the push stroke, like a cheap construction saw from Lowe's. Those things are terrible. They're garbage. They're very hard to use if you're just like breaking down two by fours or whatever. But if you try to do what Jason said, it's very difficult. Instead, just buy yourself a very cheap Dozuki, which is like a pool saw. So it's actually really thin and flexible, so you can't push it. So it only tensions and then uses the tension of the steel to cut. It's a much more ergonomic.
这需要一点时间来适应，但锯路，也就是刀片的厚度，比西式锯薄得多。你得给我解释一下。我以为当你锯东西时，你是双向锯的，你推和拉。西式锯在推的过程中切割，它们有厚刀片，金属部分很厚，它们的齿被磨成一定角度，以便在推的过程中切割。廉价的锯子通常是电磁硬化的，它们加热边缘并以特定方式使其非常坚硬，所以它们无法被磨利。旧的锯子可以磨。而日本人有这种非常薄的金属板锯，在拉的过程中切割。所以它们被称为……你刚才让我大开眼界了。
It takes a little bit of getting used to, but the curve, the thickness of the blade, it's a lot thinner than a Western-style saw. You have to explain this to me. I thought that when you saw something that you saw in both directions, you push and you pull western saws cut on the push stroke and they have like thick blades like thick the the metal part and their teeth are sharpened at an angle to cut on the push push stroke and the cheap ones are often like electromagnetically hardened like they heat up the edges and make them very hard in a specific way so they can't be sharpened old ones can be and then the japanese have this like very thin metal plate saw that cuts on the pool the pool stroke so they're called you just blew my mind
因为，你知道，当你在电视上看到人们锯啊锯，你必须……是的，你必须来回锯，因为你的手臂不能一直朝一个方向运动。但就像你说的，当他们拉的时候，他们其实并没有在拉的部分做任何功，那只是为了下一次推做准备。是的，确实。我的意思是，我们会擦伤……所以当你开始时，你通常会拉一下来开始，但实际的切割，动力冲程是推。哇，我现在大开眼界了。好吧，哦……所以拉……是的，我的意思是，是的，这解释了为什么我锯的所有东西看起来都像垃圾。所以你只需要……是的，在特定的冲程上施加压力和推力。另外，看YouTube视频关于如何对齐切割，大多数人，包括我在内，当我追求……时，就像你把切割线对准你的身体前方，就在你的胸骨前面，但你必须……
because like you know when you watch tv you see people like saw saw saw you have to go yeah you have to go back and forth because your arm can't just keep going one direction but like you're saying when they pull they're not like actually doing any work in the pull part it's just getting them ready for the next push yes it does i mean we'll bruise so like when you're getting started you'll often pull to get started but then the actual cut the power stroke is the push wow my mind is blown right now okay oh uh so the pull yeah i mean yeah this explains why everything i cut looks like garbage so you only need to yeah put pressure and push on the certain stroke also watching like a youtube video about how to line up for the cut most people like me included when i was pursuing is like you line up the cut in front of your body like in front of your sternum but then you have to like
扭曲你的手臂来……哦，对了。那行不通。所以你实际上想对齐切割，这样你可以把手肘垂直放下，贴在身体旁边，就像火车旁边的活塞臂一样。你想做那个动作。所以如果你把切割线对齐，垂直设置，然后那样来回移动，那也是另一个相关的“笨时刻”。我的斧头用过之后太烂了。我有一把像家得宝买的那种普通斧头，一端是平的，另一端有刀片。所以当我劈木头时，我会把斧头插进木头里，然后拿一把大锤敲斧头顶部来完成劈木。结果我那样做完全把斧头弄坏了。所以我去买另一把斧头，结果我拿的那把斧头上面竟然有“禁止用大锤敲击”的标志。
kink your arm to like make it Oh, right. It doesn't work. So you actually want to line up the cut so that you can drop your elbow straight down next to your body and just make a choo-choo train, like a little piston arm on the side of the train. You want to make that motion. And so if you line the cut up, set it up vertically, and then go back and forth that way that also is another kind of a related kind of dumb moment where my uh my axe was just kind of too messed up after use i have this like it's like a regular axe you buy from home depot so it's kind of flat on one end and it's got a blade on the other end and so when i would chop wood i would put the axe in the wood and then I'd take a sledgehammer and I would hit the top of the axe to like finish splitting the wood. And so I completely broke my axe doing that. And so then I went to get another axe and it actually, the axe I picked up actually has like a no hitting with sledgehammer sign.
就像……很难把那个画成一个火柴人挥舞大锤敲斧头的标志，这有点难做到，所以我得称赞他们。我说，哦，我会买那种可以用大锤敲的。所以我又买了一把，结果发现……没有那种斧头。是的，你买一个楔子。是的，有一个特殊的楔子你放进去。是的，所以我学到了惨痛的教训，你必须在木头里有那个小缝隙后，用楔子代替斧头，然后用大锤敲那个楔子。哦，你知道，伐木工先辈们会感到骄傲的。看，我从来没参加过童子军。你参加过童子军吗？
Like it was pretty, it's kind of hard to put that into like having a stick figure swinging a sledgehammer at an axe with a no it's like kind of hard to do that so i have to commend them on that and i was like oh i was like oh i'll get the i'll get the the one you can hit with a sledge hammer so i picked up another and turns out like none of them yeah you buy a wedge yeah there's a special wedge you drop in yeah so i learned the hard way that uh you have to like replace the axe with the wedge once you have the little niche in there and then hit that with a sledgehammer. Oh, the, you know, lumberjack forefathers would be proud. See, I never did Boy Scouts. Did you ever do Boy Scouts?
我没有。我从来没参加过。哦，看，是的。那你怎么学到所有这些的？只是通过你的父母之类的？看，这就是我的问题，我的家人取笑我，无论什么最基本的任务，如果我不是百分之百确定我在做什么，YouTube。是的，那真的很聪明。我的意思是，基本上，如果
I did not. I never did. Oh, see, yeah. So how did you learn all of this? Just through your parents and stuff like that? See, that's my problem like my family makes fun of me whatever take the most basic task if i'm not a hundred percent sure i know what i'm doing youtube yeah that is a really smart i mean pretty much so if
我不是百分之百确定我在做什么，基本上就是……破坏东西，做饭时触发烟雾报警器，你知道。是的，我想一些YouTube视频可能对我很有帮助。好吧，我那个令人惊讶的有用东西本来是这些昂贵的18美元指甲剪，但我觉得我们现在完全偏离了木工主题。等等，好吧，等等，我现在对这个很好奇。这比普通指甲剪好在哪里？它们只是很锋利，所以它们就像……事实证明，你真的不应该一辈子只用指甲剪，把它们扔进抽屉里，然后从来不更换。事实证明，它们可以变得非常非常锋利，所以你不必……
i'm not a hundred percent sure what i'm doing it's pretty much uh destroy things that's set off smoke alarms when cooking you know yeah I think some YouTube could probably do me some good alright so my surprisingly useful thing was gonna be these fancy $18 nail clippers but like I feel like we are totally out of woodworking theme now so wait a minute okay wait hang on now I'm curious about this like how is this uh better than regular nail clippers they're just like sharp so they just like it turns out you're not really supposed to just use nail clippers like your whole life like throw them in a drawer and you know just like never replace them turns out they can just be like really really sharp so you don't have to like
如果你在指甲剪背面施加压力来让它切割，你就做错了。哦，它应该是一个非常轻松的动作，它应该非常锋利且非常容易切割。所以我……是的，我学到了这一点。其实，我会顺着这个话题说，我最近更换了我们所有的炊具，不是全部，但大部分。嗯，我们从约会开始就一直用同样的炊具，嗯，你只要说锅碗瓢盆之类的。所以，嗯，我决定，你知道，多花点钱，我买了这口锅，真的很好。
if you're putting pressure on the back of the nail clipper to make it cut you're doing it wrong oh like it should just be a very easy motion like it should be nice and sharp and very easy to cut so i yeah i learned this actually i'll i'll i'll riff off of that i recently replaced all of our cookware not all of it but a lot of it um so we be using the same cookware since we were dating and, uh, um, you just say pots and pans and all of that. And so, um, I decided to, you know, spend a little bit more money and I got this, uh, this pan that was really nice.
它基本上，它摸起来和看起来有点像铸铁，但它不是，它是防粘的，你知道，而且表面简直太棒了。就像我们现在煎鸡蛋，几乎不需要任何油或黄油，鸡蛋就在上面滑来滑去。嗯，也许这两个故事的寓意是，你知道，不要20年都用同样的指甲剪和锅碗瓢盆，你应该时不时更换这些东西。好吧。我们现在暴露年龄了。就像我们……是的。好吧。
It basically, it kind of feels and looks like cast iron, but it's not, it's nonstick, you know, and, and the, the surface is just phenomenal. Like we cook an egg now and you barely need any oil or butter like the egg just slides around and uh yeah maybe the moral of these two stories is to you know don't have the same no tail no uh toe clippers and pots and pans for 20 years like you'll replace these things every now and then. All right. We're just dating ourselves now. Like we're, yeah. Okay.
我们应该进入新闻环节了。好吧。新闻时间。你来吧。是的。我先来。等你听到这个的时候，无论时态是什么，都搞砸了。
We should move on to the news. All right. Time for news. Take it away. Yeah. Mine's up first. By the time you will have had listened to this, whatever the tent is messed up.
希望这次非常成功，但我很兴奋。它终于要发生了。看起来这周，SpaceX要点燃他们星舰（Starship）上的所有33台发动机。他们已经把所有东西都堆叠好了，助推器和星舰本身坐在顶部。他们要点燃所有33台发动机，
Hopefully this has gone very successful, but I'm excited. It's finally happening. It seems like this week, SpaceX is going to light up all 33 of the engines on their Starship. They have it all stacked up, the booster and the Starship itself sitting on the top. They're going to light off all 33 engines
为尝试轨道试飞做准备。这超级超级令人兴奋。他们经历了很多……我不会深入细节，只是在从上一次试飞（那是很久以前的事了）到准备进入轨道之间经历了很多波折。我非常希望这次能成功。如果是这样，他们总是说失败的可能性很大，这可能是真的。但我希望这次能成功。看到这个项目再次推进会很棒。同样令人兴奋的是，他们对它很有信心。他们现在正在德克萨斯州和佛罗里达州加大生产力度。他们要真正尝试去
in preparation for attempting an orbital test flight. This is super, super exciting. They went through, I won't get into it, just a lot of drama trying to get from their last test flights, which were a while ago, to getting ready to go to orbit. I'm super hopeful this will be successful. If so, they always say there's a large chance of failure, which is probably true. But I hope this will be successful. It would be great to see the program moving on again. It's also exciting to see that they have a lot of faith in it. They're ramping up production both in Texas and in Florida now. And they're going to sort of really try going for
做这件事。这很令人兴奋。我现在住在佛罗里达。你忘了你以前住在这里，现在又住在这里，它过去就是这样，但现在更是如此。基本上每周或每周多次都有火箭发射。所以你只是……就像这样，但现在更是如此。基本上每周或每周多次都有火箭发射。所以你只是……遛狗的时候，哦嘿，看，有个火箭升空了。只是偶然发生的，这太棒了，太疯狂了。回到那种节奏真的很棒。每当我们做预测时，我总是对太空做预测，但我真的认为人们低估了这可能有多大，所以我很兴奋。其实，给我们介绍一下背景，什么是星舰？哦，我没把笔记整理好，但……做笔记……但要点是，你知道，这是SpaceX的下一个发射系统，所以他们有新型发动机，
it. And that's exciting. I live in Florida now. And you forgot from having lived here a while ago and now living here again, that it used to be like this, but even now it's more so. There are rocket launches basically like every week or multiple times a week. So you'll just be like this but even now it's more so there are rocket launches basically like every week or multiple times a week so you'll just be like walking your dog and like oh hey look there's a rocket going up uh just by happenstance which is awesome crazy it's so good to be back to where like that cadence is is really up there whenever we do the predictions i always make predictions about space but i really think it's underrepresented just how like big this could be so i'm pumped actually give us a background what is the starship oh i didn't i didn't get myself my notes together but uh make notes uh but the gist is it's you know spacex's next launch systems so they have new kinds of engines
这些全流量分级燃烧循环发动机，这些特殊的新型发动机，不同于我现在有的那些。不同的……你管它叫什么，底盘？就像……好吧，火箭。而不是现在的液体燃料火箭，顶部只有一个小东西，你知道，不能装太多东西。你不能把人放在带有他们现在有的龙飞船（Dragon capsule）的顶部，或者可以装载货物，但即使它比周围的其他东西好得多，也便宜得多，仍然相对有限。但现在他们正在研发星舰，它本身就有更大的载货能力。发动机
the these like this full cycle float these like special kind of new engines different from the ones i have now a different what do you want to call like a chassis like the okay the rocket and instead of right now it's mostly the liquid fuel rocket and then a tiny little thing at the top right that is you know can't really hold all that much you can't put people on the top with the capsule that they have the dragon capsule or can put cargo but it's still even though it's it's much better than most of the other stuff going around and a lot cheaper still relatively limited but now they're working on the starship which is going to be on its own just like much more cargo capacity the engines
效率更高，它是为了这种提升而设计的，他们计划好了一切，这样他们真的可以去火星。所以会有……你把燃料送到太空，然后发射一枚火箭，然后从之前的火箭给火箭加油。他们正在这里制定整个物流链，以及他们需要让它运行的正确的东西。但从根本上说，它只是一枚大得多的火箭。所以我认为它旗鼓相当。我觉得上次我看到它时还有争议，
are much more efficient it's meant for this ramp up where they're attempting to have it all planned out so they can actually go to mars so there will will be, you put fuel up into space, then launch a rocket, then refuel the rocket from the previous rocket. There's a whole logistics chain that they're working out here and the right sort of stuff that they need to get that going. But fundamentally, it's just a much, much larger rocket. So I think it's right on par. I feel like it got debated last time I saw it,
但基本上它是最强大的，或者就在最强大的火箭之列。但最重要的是，它不仅如此，而且因为它更可重复使用，效率更高，所以它也会非常便宜。因此，发射那枚火箭会便宜得多，这基本上降低了进入太空的每磅成本。
but basically the most powerful or right at the most powerful sort of rocket to go up. But on top of that, it's not only that it's also going to be enormously cheap because it's far more reusable, far more efficient. So it's going to be much cheaper to launch that rocket, which drives down the price like per pound to get to space basically.
所以现在进入太空只有在你有超级好的用例或者资金非常充足的情况下才有效。但如果你能把成本降下来，你就不需要那么多借口把东西送上去，这意味着送上去的东西数量会多得多。这说得通。我周末有个疯狂的想法，我很想让你反驳一下。所以……好吧，前提是，我假设太空中有些岩石里有贵金属，比如……是的，好吧……所以你能重定向其中一个，让它撞向沙漠中心，然后当它撞击地球时开采它吗？你会摧毁大气层吗？那是可行的吗？那是我们
So it's only efficient to go to space right now. If you have like a super good use case or you're very well funded but if you can drive that down you need much less of a you know excuse to put something up which means the amount of stuff going up will will be a lot higher that makes sense i had this crazy idea over the weekend and i'd love for you to debunk this but so well okay the premise here is i assume that in space there are rocks with with precious metals in them like like yeah okay so so could you redirect one of those to like crash into the middle of the desert and then mine it when it hits the earth and like would you would you kind of destroy the atmosphere like is that how tenable is that is that ever something we
在未来一个世纪左右能看到的事情吗？人们谈论过，我想，为了地球改造的目的，把某些小行星撞向火星，加热它，做各种各样的事情。我从来没听过有人说为了开采的目的。我想它要么太大，会造成巨大的问题，要么太小，会在疯狂的高温下焚毁。但人们谈论的是把小行星移动到更好或更邻近的轨道，
could see happen in the next like century or something uh people have talked about i think crashing certain makeup asteroids into mars for sort of the purpose of doing terraforming and like heat it up do various things i've never heard someone say that like that the for the purpose of mining i think too much it would either be so big, there'd be a huge problem or too small and it would incinerate from the crazy heat. But what they have talked about is moving asteroids into a better or more adjacent orbit,
开采这些东西并把它带下来，这会造成绝对的混乱。为什么你要把这些东西带下来，而不是把整个小行星带下来？就像，是因为……哦，因为要穿过……是的，所以你有一条细线，你要么摧毁你试图带下来的东西，要么摧毁住在这里的所有人。这是一种需要平衡的走钢丝。这就是恐龙发生的事情，他们说恐龙的宇宙飞船试图把一颗充满黄金的小行星重定向到地球。
mining the stuff and bringing it down, which would cause absolute chaos. Why would you bring this stuff down when you could just bring the whole asteroid down? Like, is it just so- Oh, because to get through yeah so you have you have this fine line between you either destroy what you're trying to bring down or you destroy all the people who live here it's kind of a kind of a balance to walk that's what happened to the dinosaurs they said they're dinosaur spaceship tried to redirect like an asteroid full of gold into the Earth.
就是那样发生的。是的。所以我认为处于地球邻近轨道更好。然后，你知道，有一种容易上下往返的方法。以及一种更符合空气动力学的、为任务制造的交通工具。或者如果你试图建造空间站之类的东西，就把它留在太空中，在现场开采并使用它。哦，那说得通。是的，酷。是的，那超级令人兴奋。我的新闻第一条是这个叫“人类运动扩散模型”（Human Motion Diffusion Model）的东西。这里的想法是，你知道，我们都见过DALL-E和Stable Diffusion以及这些其他东西，你输入
That's what happened. Yeah. So I think being in a sort of Earth adjacent orbit is better. And then, you know, having a way to get up and down easily. And a more aerodynamic, you know, made for the task sort of vehicle. Or if you're trying to construct space stations and stuff, just leaving it up in space and mining it and using it on site as it were oh that makes sense yeah cool yeah that's super exciting my news first news story is this thing called the human motion diffusion model so the idea here is you know we've all kind of seen dolly and stable diffusion and these these other things where you type in
类似……你知道，在海滩上行走，宇航员在海滩上行走之类的东西，它会为你画一张图。这个的作用有点不同，你输入一个动作，它为你动画化一个角色。所以他们有这个人体骨架（armature），就像一个三维的……把它想象成一个骨架，对吧，你可以动画化它。所以它有一堆小关节，有点像我们小时候玩的那些纸偶，你在上面打孔，它们可以在那些关节上活动，但在3D中。所以游戏的工作方式，例如，是有人会穿上一套衣服，那套衣服上有一堆传感器。那个人会做一个后空翻或跳到空中
something like uh you know walking on the beach astronaut walking on the beach or something and it will draw a picture for you what this does is a little different you type um an action and it animates a character for you so they have this human body armature which is like a three-dimensional kind of think of it as like a skeleton right that you can animate so it's got a bunch of little joints uh kind of like one of these um you know paper puppets that we had when we were kids where you punch holes in it and they could articulate on those on those ambulate on those on those joints, but in 3D. And so the way games, for example, work is someone will wear a suit and that suit will have a bunch of sensors on it. And that person will do a somersault or jump into the air
或类似的事情，穿着那套衣服。然后传感器会让你捕捉那个动作。他们称之为Mocap或动作捕捉，然后让游戏中的角色，只要它有点像人，做同样的事情。所以有人做的是，他们收集了大量带有标签的动作捕捉数据。例如，有人会说，你知道，行走，然后他们会让一个穿衣服的人行走，然后他们会捕捉那个数据，他们会让这个小3D骨架行走。他们有跳跃，
or something like that with the suit. And then the sensors will allow you to take that motion and capture it. They call it mocap or motion capture, and then have your character in the game, as long as it's somewhat human-like, do the same thing. And so what someone has done is they've collected a ton of this motion capture data with labels. So for example, someone will say, you know, walking, and then they'll have a person in a suit walk, and then they'll capture that data and they'll make it so now this little 3D armature can walk and they have jumping,
他们有挥手，他们有所有这些东西。所以，你知道，有了那个数据集，有人把它放进了驱动DALL-E和Stable AI以及所有这些东西的同类技术中。他们创造了这个东西，你可以输入“做一个后空翻，然后击掌”。就像你可以输入那个词，一个句子，它会为那个动作生成一个动画，这看起来真的很酷。所以他们这里有一些例子。
they have waving, they have all these things. And so, you know, with that data set, someone put it into the same kind of technology that powers, you know, DALI and stable instability AI and all that. And they created this thing where you can type in, doing a somersault, then giving a high five. Like you could just type that word in, a sentence in, and it will generate an animation for that, which is really cool to watch. So they have some examples here.
一个人跳绳，一个人缓慢向后走，你可以输入几乎任何东西，让这个小骨架为你做那个动作。是的，我去看了那些片段，那真的很酷。我想……是的，那种“做这个动作，但像喝醉了一样跌跌撞撞”的细微差别，或者做这个动作。然后修饰语非常有趣，似乎……很难不把它拟人化，但你可以，它几乎感觉像是理解了你的要求。是的，完全正确。
A person skipping a rope, a person walks backwards slowly, and you can type pretty much anything and get this this little uh you know armature to do that for you yeah i went and viewed those clips that is that is pretty cool i think the yeah nuance of like do this thing but stumble around like you're drunk or do this thing. And then modifiers is pretty interesting that it seemed, it's always hard not to anthropomorphize it, but you can, it almost feels like it understands what you're asking for. Yeah, exactly.
而且，你知道，至少它是变分（variational）的。所以如果你在游戏或元宇宙里有一群人，一群AI代理在行走，他们都会……在元宇宙里，一群AI代理在行走，他们都会走得有点不同，有了这样的东西。哦，我没考虑到这一点。所以，是的，同样的提示词不会每次都给你同样的结果。是的，完全正确，这里有随机性元素。很酷。我的下一条新闻文章，我想我们在这里像跷跷板一样，但这没关系，是37 Signals，我不知道，我会说它部分最出名的是它的创始人DHH，以及他有趣的观点。我们前几天在播客上谈论过这个，
And, you know, if nothing else, it's variational. So like if you had a bunch of people in a game or in the metaverse or something, a bunch of AI agents walking, they would all in the metaverse or something a bunch of ai agents walking they would all walk a little bit differently with something like this oh i didn't think about that so yeah the same prompt doesn't give you the same same result every time yeah exactly like there's element of randomness here pretty cool my next uh news article, I guess we're seesawing around here, but that's okay, is the 37 Signals, which is, I don't know, I would say is sort of partly most famous for its founder, DHH, and his interesting takes. And we were talking about that on the podcast the other day,
但他因为Ruby on Rails和做很多那类事情而出名。我想，那是做Basecamp的人吗？是的，没错。哦，明白了。Basecamp，是的，还有一套工具。所以他们对很多事情都非常直言不讳，包括不想接受风险投资，保持自筹资金，保持小规模，负责任地成长，
but he's famous for sort of Ruby on Rails and doing a lot of that stuff. I think, is that the person who made Basecamp, I think? Yes, that's right. Okay, got it. Basecamp, yeah, and a suite of tools. And so they've been very vocal about a lot of things, including not wanting to take venture capital funding, being sort of self-funded and sort of staying small, growing responsibly,
高效编程，你知道，与他们所说的硅谷初创公司中许多浪费行为背道而驰。显然，他们在探索技术、理解、保持相关性方面也非常成功，所有这些事情。好吧，这就是背景。
programming efficiently, you know, counter to, I guess, what they would say is a lot of the waste in typical Silicon Valley startups. And then obviously they've been pretty successful in exploring technologies, understanding, staying relevant, like all of these things. Okay, that's all set up.
所以DHH在Twitter线程上一直在谈论他们曾经使用云服务，并且在很多事情上使用AWS，但它对他们来说并不奏效。基本上他们要停止那样做。他们要为自己内部运行自己的服务器。他们认为他们将能够节省很多钱。作为其中的一部分，我想你可能会称之为“激进透明度”，他同意在Twitter线程中发布他们花了多少钱以及他们在AWS上使用了什么。我不是
So DHH on a Twitter thread has been talking about that they had gone to the cloud and been using AWS for a lot of stuff, but that it wasn't working for them. And that basically they were going to stop doing that. And they were going to run their own servers internally for just themselves. And they thought that they were going to be able to save a lot of money. As part of that, and I guess like what you might call radical transparency, he agreed to post how much they were spending and what they were using on AWS in a Twitter thread. I'm not
要读那些细节。如果你对那些数字感兴趣，请去读那个Twitter线程。但他给出了很多关于他们花了多少钱的细分，为什么他们觉得太多了，将其与来自戴尔或其他公司的重型服务器基础设施的成本进行了比较。这引发了很多对话，好吧，很多。它在各个社区引发了一波对话，我看到人们要么支持他，要么阐述AWS或谷歌云平台或Azure是如何非常擅长说服你每次多花一点钱，只是增加你的支出并进行
going to read the details of that. Please go read the Twitter thread if you're interested in those numbers. But he gives a lot of breakdown about what they were spending, why they feel like it was too much, comparing it to the costs of like heavy duty server infrastructure from just, you know, sort of Dell or whomever. And it sort of started a lot of conversation, well, a lot. It started a ripple of conversation in various communities that I saw about people either sort of agreeing with him and sort of espousing how AWS or Google Cloud Platform or Azure, they're very good at convincing you to spend ever slightly more money each time and just sort of grow your spend and have
谈判。其他人说很多人只是没有预料到它会变得多么昂贵，也没有花时间去优化和提高效率。人们指出他存储了大量数据，几PB的存储。所以如果你看普通客户和他相比，他们使用的存储量占他们预算的比例比大多数用例都要高。很多人抛出随机的，也许他们不知道发生了什么，或者那个人可能稍微更了解他在做什么，就像随机的，“哦，去无服务器（serverless），哦，做这个，哦，做那个”。但这只是引发了有趣的对话，因为我认为很多公司不会在公开场合这样做，初创公司会说他们
negotiations. Other people saying that a lot of folks just don't anticipate how expensive it's going to be and really spend the time optimizing and being efficient. People pointing out he was storing a lot of data, several petabytes of storage. So if you look at the average customer versus him, the amount of storage they were using was a higher percentage of their budget than most use cases. A lot of people throwing random, maybe they don't know what's going on or that the person may know slightly more of what they're doing, just like random to, oh, go serverless, oh, do this, oh, do that. But it just started this interesting conversation because I think a lot of folks don't do this out in public and startups will say how
在云上花了多少钱之类的，但人们会认为，我们不知道你在做什么，对吧？在这里，我们有一个人，很难对他进行“你不知道你在做什么”的指责。尽管可能有一些批评，嘿，你本可以改变一些东西。你需要这样计划。你不能只是带进来一个AWS的人，因为他们只会做所有AWS的事情，而不担心成本。但也只是关于它到底有多昂贵，以及没有真正好的方法来进行同类比较的更广泛的对话。举个例子，如果你说，哦，我把所有这些数据存储在S3中，几PB。好吧，首先，几PB是许多许多许多许多硬盘驱动器，它们放在一个位置。
much they spend on cloud or whatever, but people kind of take that as, we don't know what you're doing, right? And here we have someone who it's pretty hard to just levy a, like, you don't know what you're doing. Although there are potentially some criticisms that, hey, you could have changed stuff around. You need to plan for it this way. You can't just bring in someone who's an AWS person because they're just going to do all the AWS things and not worry about the cost. But also just this broader conversation about how expensive it really is and that there isn't really a good way to do an apples to apples comparison. So as an example, if you say, oh, I have all this data stored in S3, several petabytes. Well, first of all, several petabytes is many, many, many, many hard drives that stick in one location.
然后你必须添加备份冗余策略。你有足够多的数据，甚至这都成了物流问题。就像你需要购买新硬盘来更换故障硬盘的速度。你需要把它们放在两个站点。你知道，所有这些东西，AWS只是在后台处理，对吧？所以你说，哦，它每兆字节花费X美分，你知道，那真的很贵。我可以去买一个硬盘，你知道，比那个每兆字节的成本低。就像，好吧，也许对于某些用例，那是相同的，但事实并非如此。所以这只是开启了一个大对话。但我认为这么久以来，每个人都说，去云端，去云端，不要
Then you've got to add like backup redundancy strategies. You have enough that even that becomes like a logistical issue. Just like the rate at which you need to buy new hard drives to swap out failing ones. You need to have them in two sites. You know, all of this stuff, AWS just under the hood, right? So you say, oh, it costs X cents per megabyte, you know, and that's really expensive. I can go buy a hard drive at, you know, less than that cents per megabyte. And it's like, well, maybe for some use cases, that's the same, but it's not really. So there's just this big conversation opened up. But I think for so long, everybody's like, go to the cloud, go to the cloud, don't
自托管。现在人们说，好吧，也许我会自托管。人们说，好吧，我们明白为什么。这只是一个非常有趣的，我猜，钟摆来回摆动，人们只是开启了那个对话。是的，非常有道理。是的，为了稍微清晰一点，绝对，你知道，人们应该阅读细节。但是的，他说对于37 Signals，那是一家公司吗？那是他的公司。是的。那是做Basecamp的公司吗？是的。哦，好吧。好吧。所以对于37 Signals，他们去年在云上花了320万。而且，是的，我想你一针见血了。我想我想我想你知道，
self-host. Now people are like saying, well, maybe I'll self-host. And people are going, well, we see why. It's just a very interesting, I guess, pendulum swing back and forth and people just opening up that conversation. Yeah, makes a ton of sense. Yeah, just for a little bit of clarity, definitely, you know, folks should read the details. But yeah, he said for 37 signals, is that a company? That's his company. Yeah. Is that the company that makes Basecamp? Yep. Oh, okay. Okay. So for 37 signals, they spent 3.2 million last year in in cloud. And yeah, I think you hit the nail on the head. I think i think i think you know the
对我来说让这变得有趣的事情是，你知道，人们会使用云作为一种不需要思考事情的方式。就像，我不想去思考……买多少服务器。我不想处于那种我必须匆忙，像紧急订购硬件并设置它的位置。所以，我认为这里的前提是，好吧，有这么多其他人使用这个云，他们可以以一种节省每个人钱的方式打包它，这种节省将证明其他一切的合理性。每个人都对那种“我有100台机器闲置”的想法感到畏缩，当你知道你可以分时共享它时……但我认为在实践中，你知道，问题在于度量单位，无论你是谈论存储还是计算，对于很多这些公司，甚至是初创公司，都太大了，以至于他们实际上无法共享很多……就像
the thing that for me that makes this interesting is you know people will use the cloud as a way to not have to think about things it's like i don't want to have to think about um how many servers to buy i don't want to be a position where i have to rush and like emergency order a piece of hardware and set it up. And so, and I think the premise here is, well, there's so many other people using this cloud that they can just kind of package it in a way that saves everyone money and that savings will justify everything else. Everyone cringes at the idea of like, I have a hundred machines that are idle right when you know you could be time sharing that um but i think in practice you know the problem is that the unit of measure whether you're talking about storage or compute for a lot of these companies even startups is just so large that they can't practically share a lot um like
你知道，你可能正在使用200.5台机器，那另外0.5台可以共享，但谁在乎呢？因为你已经在使用200台完整的机器了。所以，是的，似乎应该有一种方法……嗯，我其实知道亚马逊有……你可以预留一整年的东西，你知道，预留一定量的使用量。使用量，是的。我真的很好奇，当这些人尝试在本地做事情时，他们是否会发现它其实并没有那么便宜……你可以买硬件，但还有所有这些其他成本，你将开始支付，特别是网络之类的东西。是的，我认为这尤其残酷，也带回了租用空间和雇佣团队成员来管理这些服务，你知道，带人来，像，组装，你知道，服务器，或者，你知道，去插上它们，把它们拧进机架。
you know you might be using 200.5 machines and that other 0.5 can be shared, but who cares? Cause you're already using 200 whole machines. So yeah, it seems like there should be a way to, um, I actually, I know Amazon has, uh, things where you can reserve for a whole year, you know, reserve some amount of, of, of usage. usage yeah i really wonder if when these people try and do things locally if they're going to find out that it's actually not that not that much cheaper like you can buy the hardware but then there's all these other costs you're going to start paying for especially network and things like that yeah i think it's especially brutal also bringing back the like renting space and hiring people on your team to go manage those services and, you know, bring somebody to, like, put together the, you know, servers or, you know, go plug them in, screw them into the rack.
我的意思是，你可以外包。所以这就像一个光谱，我猜。但我认为我们可能会看到，而且很多这些，他甚至提到了关于预留实例与竞价实例（spot instances）以及长期谈判合同和所有这些事情。所以看起来他相当认真地做了功课，但我认为这将是一个非常混合的解决方案，我认为当你快速变化时，也许你只是去云端。一旦你稳定下来，你就会引入内部并优化一些非常稳定的部分，但允许弹性部分存在于云端。它的每单位计算成本更高，但想法是你把它关掉，对吧？
I mean, you can outsource. So it's like a spectrum, I guess. But I think what we'll probably see, and so a lot of this, and he even brings these things up about like reserve versus spot instances and long-term negotiated contracts and all of these things. So it seems like he's reasonably done his homework, but I think it'll be a very hybrid solution where I think when you're rapidly changing around, maybe you just go to the cloud. Once you sort of stabilize out, you bring internal and optimize some very steady portion, but then allow the flex to live sort of on the cloud. And it's higher per unit of computation, but the idea is you turn it off, right?
我的意思是，你可以外包。所以这大概是一个光谱。但我认为我们可能会看到的情况是，他甚至提到了预留实例与竞价实例、长期协商合同等等。所以他似乎做了相当充分的功课，但我认为这将是一个非常混合的解决方案。我认为当你需要快速变动时，也许你直接使用云服务。一旦情况稳定下来，你就会引入内部资源并优化一些非常稳定的部分，但同时允许弹性需求保留在云端。虽然单位计算成本更高，但理念是你可以随时关闭它，对吧？
Or you don't use it all the time. And so there's this problem of sizing for the peak. Back in the yay old days of the internet, right? It was like even earlier, but like eventually this is where the slash dot effect, if your article got posted on slash dot, you know, millions of visitors would show up. And if your website doesn't respond, you're never getting that traffic back again. And so there's this like sizing for the peak. But if you size for the peak all the time, as Jason mentioned, then you're going to hover around like 1% utilization on average. Like that's not useful either. And so I think these sort of hybrid where you use a lot of it for overflow and you have it set up. But that's also a more complicated solution. So I don't know. Yeah, you need like a load balancer now that spans your internal like warehouse and Amazon and like redirects the traffic and all of that yeah that's
或者你并不总是使用它。因此，这就存在一个为峰值需求进行规模规划的问题。回到互联网的“远古时代”，对吧？甚至更早，但最终这就是“Slashdot效应”的由来，如果你的文章被发布在Slashdot上，你知道，会有数百万访客涌入。如果你的网站没有响应，你就永远无法挽回那些流量了。所以存在这种“为峰值规划规模”的问题。但正如Jason所提到的，如果你一直按峰值来规划规模，那么平均利用率就会徘徊在1%左右。这也没什么用。所以我认为这种混合模式，即利用大量资源来处理溢出流量并进行配置，是一种解决方案。但这同样是一个更复杂的方案。所以我不知道。是的，你现在需要一个负载均衡器，它能跨越你的内部仓库和亚马逊云，并重定向流量等等，是的，这确实是
yeah there's got to be a product like that um but yeah it's it's you're right it adds complexity to everything but uh yeah that's fascinating um yeah i mean that that's that's uh i think that's going to be a big area i know actually they're doing a lot around this with storage. So there's a min IO and a bunch of S3 compliant storage where you could even use Amazon's SDK to read and write data from your own local data center. So it's like something like that for compute or for web services or something could get us there. My second news story is Polar's data frames in Rust. So Patrick, have you ever used Pandas? Yes, but not extensively. Yeah.
是的，肯定有这样的产品，嗯，但你是对的，它增加了所有事情的复杂性，但嗯，这太迷人了，嗯，我的意思是，我认为这将是一个很大的领域，我实际上知道他们在存储方面做了很多工作。所以有MinIO和一堆兼容S3的存储，你甚至可以使用亚马逊的SDK从你自己的本地数据中心读取和写入数据。所以，类似这样的计算或Web服务的东西可能会让我们实现这一点。我的第二个新闻是Rust中的Polars数据框。那么Patrick，你用过Pandas吗？用过，但不深入。是的，我猜是不太深入。我写过一些脚本，尝试过一些东西，但我从来没有在日常工作中用它编程。好的，明白了，你从来没有在工作中提交过PR，里面包含Pandas代码，对吧？没有。好的，那么R有一个很棒的东西，或者说有一个很棒的东西
So Pandas, have you ever used R? No. Yes. Okay. I say, I guess like not extensive. I've scripted a few things and tried some stuff but i've never day-to-day programmed in it okay got it got you've never like checked in a pr at work that was our code for sure no okay so so r had this amazing thing or has this amazing thing
叫做数据框（data frames），其理念基本上就像一个Excel电子表格，只不过不是列，你知道，我是在第三列，我是在第四列。也许我会给它加个字母。我是在A列，B列。取而代之的是，每一列都有一个名字。所以你可以说，嗯，这一列。是的，这就是人们使用Excel的方式，对吧？他们做的第一件事就是在第一行给所有列命名。所以让我们把它变成一个一等公民，所以一个
called data frames the idea is it's basically like an Excel spreadsheet, except instead of columns, which are just, you know, I'm on column three, I'm on column four. Maybe I'll put a letter on it. I'm on column A, B. Instead of that, each column has a name. So you can say, well, this column. Yeah, and this is what people do with Excel, right? The first thing they do is in the first row, they title all of the columns. So let's just like make that a first class citizen so so a
数据框基本上是一组序列（series），每个序列都被赋予一个名字，这是一种处理数据的好方法，这几乎是你在R中处理大多数数据的方式，并且围绕它有大量的支持。所以Pandas是一个用于Python的数据框库。所以这个想法是，如果你想在Python中拥有这种结构，你就使用Pandas。它支持以多种不同格式读取和写入，你可以将其序列化为Arrow格式以供其他程序读取，它还有各种各样的实用工具。问题是它相当慢，绝对没有R的那个快，而且总的来说，它的性能不是很好，它几乎全部是用纯Python编写的。所以Polars基本上是用Rust对Pandas数据框的完全重写，嗯，它仍然是一个Python库，但在底层，它
data frame is basically a set of series and each series is given a name and it's a nice way of working with data it's pretty much the way that r you work with most data in r and there's a bunch of support around that so pandas is a data frame library for Python. So the idea is you want to have that construct in Python, you use pandas. And so it supports like reading and writing in a bunch of different formats, you can serialize it to arrow to read into another program, has all sorts of nice utilities to it. The thing is it's pretty slow it's definitely not as fast as the r1 um and in general it's just it's just not very performant it's a lot almost all of is written in pure python so polars is basically a total rewrite of of pandas data frames in rust and um it's still a python library but under the hood it's it's it's
全部是用Rust完成的，而且速度快得惊人，所以它非常非常酷。如果你们中有谁在使用Pandas，我的猜测是，你知道，它可能不是完全的API兼容，所以当你移植过来时，你可能会遇到Bug或者说差异，但只要稍微努力一下，你就可以使用Polars。所以Polars本身就是纯Rust，所以它是Rust代码，但它周围有一个Python包装器，而且有大量数据表明它有多快。这很有趣，我想这里说他们正在使用Apache Arrow和Parquet的东西，这很酷，所以我认为我们从来没有真正深入讨论过这一点，但这就是
all done in rust and it's insanely fast so it's uh really really cool if any of you out there are using pandas my guess is just you know it's probably not you know totally api compliant so you're probably going to get bugs or let's say differences uh you know when you port over but but with a little bit of work you can uh you can uh you can use polars uh so polars by itself is just kind of pure rust so it's rust code but there is a like a python wrapper around it and there's a whole bunch of data showing how insanely fast it is this is interesting i guess here it says they're using the apache arrow stuff in parquet which is pretty cool so that i don't think we've ever really like gone over that but that's the
列式存储格式，所以Python或C++中的大多数结构都是你所说的“结构数组”（array of structures），所以如果你有数据表示为，你知道，有一个时间戳、一个标签，以及无论发生了什么活动，枚举等等，对吧？然后你就会有一个数组，该数组的内存布局是：布尔值、整数、双精度浮点数，布尔值、整数、双精度浮点数，布尔值、整数、双精度浮点数，其中每一个都是数组中该结构的一个实例。你会得到一个非常扁平的数据模型。问题是，如果你真的想查询，比如“给我所有小于这个值的双精度浮点数”，那种内存访问方式就很糟糕，因为计算机提取的是整个连续的内存块，即一行。哦，这里“行”这个词有歧义。
columnar sort of format so most structures in python or sort of c++ are what you would call i guess like an array of structures so if you had like your data as represented as you know has a time stamp and a label and uh whatever activity happened in enum whatever right and then you would have an array and the in-memory layout of that array is like bool int double, bool int double, bool int double, where each one of those is one of the instances of that structure in an array. And you get this very flat data model. The problem is if you actually want to query, like give me all of the doubles that are less than this value, that memory access kind of sucks because the computer pulls down like an entire contiguous block of memory, a row. Oh, row is ambiguous here.
一整块连续的内存。然后它必须跳跃，而你只用到了三分之一。不是，总之，当你遍历时，你只用到了数据的一小部分，对吧？所以，与其使用这种列式格式Parquet Arrow，而且听起来这个Rust库正试图利用这一点，不如使用“数组结构”（structure of arrays），或者说数组的数组，即我把所有的布尔值放在一起，所有的双精度浮点数放在一起，如果你要进行这类查询，
An entire contiguous set of memory. And then it has to jump across and you're only using one third. It's not, but anyways, using one fraction of the data as you march across, right? So instead of this columnar format parquet arrow, and it sounds like this Rust library is trying to take advantage of that, is instead if it's a structure of arrays where you say, or an array of arrays, where I have all my bools together, all the doubles together, and if you're going to do these kinds of queries,
优势在于它们的索引匹配。所以每个数组中索引为7的位置代表你结构的一个实例。但你可以通过抓取那些数据块并遍历它们来扫描数组，你知道，根据你的结构有多大，速度会显著加快，这正是Pandas数据框试图做的事情。就像，你经常编写这些查询，这是最酷的部分，说，嘿，给我那些列等于这个且那列小于那个的项目。你正在做这些介于SQL连接和Excel电子表格之间的事情，以得出这些非常强大的结果。
the advantage is their index match. So index 7 across each of the arrays represents one instance of your structure. But you can scan the array by grabbing those blocks of data down and going through them, you know, depending on how large your structure is significantly faster, which the pandas data frames is exactly trying to do. Like, you're often writing these queries, which is the cool part, saying, hey, give me the give me the items whose column this is equal to that and this column is less than that. And you're doing these almost sort of somewhere between SQL joins and Excel spreadsheet to come up with these very powerful things.
但正如Jason提到的，底层的数据访问可能是一个制约因素。是的，完全正确。是的，你一针见血，我想。是的，我认为说“哦，我有一个用户列表，所以让我只使用一个用户对象数组”是非常自然的，但正如你所说，一旦你想做某种分析，你的性能就会被拖垮，所以，这是一个很好的方式来补充另一个可以处理所有
But like Jason mentioned, the underlying data access can be a gating factor there. Yeah, totally. Yeah, you hit the nail on the head, I think. Yeah, I think it's so natural to say like oh i have you know a list of users so let me just use an array of user objects but then as you said you get killed on performance as soon as you want to do some kind of analytics and so um this is a really nice way to complement that with another data structure that can handle all
这些的数据结构，而且我们最近在工作中切换到了Polars，我们对此非常满意。你是从Python中使用它，还是现在在用Rust做东西？不，全是Python。啊，呜。Python运行在Rust之上，Rust运行在C++之上。哦，它一直深入到底层。
of that and and uh, we've recently, that work switched over to Polar as we've been really happy with it. Do you use it from in Python or you're doing stuff in Rust now? No, it's all Python. Ah, ooh. Python on top of Rust on top of C++. Oh, it just goes all the way down.
好的。嗯，你知道，我不知道Polars是否使用C++。可能一直到底层都是Rust。哦，只是Rust。好的。是的，我想是这样。但它实际上是完全透明的，当你pip install时，你根本不需要知道任何关于Rust的东西，也许会编译一些代码，我老实说甚至还不知道它是怎么工作的，但嗯，但就像你把它当作Python代码来对待一样，我的意思是，你上次需要查看Pandas代码来看看它在做什么是什么时候？从来没有。就像它只是能用，或者你去Stack Overflow上查。
Okay. Well, you know, I don't know if Polar uses C++. It might just be Rust all the way down. Oh, it's just Rust. Okay. Yeah, I think so. But it it's uh yeah it's actually totally transparent you don't have to know anything about rust when you pip install i guess maybe compile some code then i don't honestly even know how it works yet but uh yeah but it's like you just treat it like it's python code and i mean when's the last time you've ever needed to look at the pandas code to see what it's doing? Like never. It's like it just it just works or you go on Stack Overflow.
所以你也可以用Rust代码做同样的事情。太棒了。我想是时候介绍本期推荐书目了。我的推荐书目是Tony Fadell的《Build》。所以Tony Fadell可能最出名的是两件事。一是作为iPod的关键设计师和产品经理之一。第二是作为Nest的首席执行官和创始人，这家公司现在制造很多东西，但最初是从恒温器开始的。你有Nest吗？我有一个同类产品，但不是Nest恒温器。嗯，你有Nest吗？我有一个同类产品，但不是Nest恒温器。我也有一个同类产品，但不是Nest。我有一个Ecobee，那是你有的那个吗？是的，所以你知道发生在我身上的事是我和某人谈过，哦，所以有人来维修我们的空调，嗯，我问那个人，你知道，哪一个更好。他说Ecobee更稳定。
So so you could do that with Rust code just the same. Awesome. I think it's time for book of the show. My book of the show is Build by Tony Fadell. So Tony Fadell is maybe most famously known for two things. One is being one of the key designers and product managers of the iPod. And the second one is being CEO and founder of Nest, which is the company that makes a bunch of things now, but originally started with a thermostat. Do you have a Nest? I have a equivalent, but not Nest thermostat um do you have a nest i have a equivalent but not to nest thermostat i also have an equivalent but not nest i have an eco bee is that the same one you have yeah so you know what happened to me was my i talked to somebody oh so someone came to service our air conditioning and um i asked that that person you know, which one was better. And he said that Ecobee is more stable.
他当时给了我一些理由。所以这不是背书。你知道，我只是真的问了暖通空调（HVAC）人员。这就是他告诉我的。所以，听听就好。但我最终也选择了Ecobee。但整个智能恒温器真是太棒了。如果你没有智能恒温器，我强烈推荐它。
He gave me some reason at the time. So it's not an endorsement. You know, I just I literally just asked the HVAC person. That's what he told me. So so take that with a grain of salt. But so I also went with Ecobee. But the whole like smart thermostat is amazing. If you don't have a smart thermostat i highly recommend it
嗯，我自己安装的，非常简单，而且你可以做一些非常不错的事情，比如，嗯，我们的加热器声音很大，而且离卧室很近，所以我们会做的是，我们会早一点运行加热器，这样房子就会变得很暖和，然后它就不需要运行一段时间了，这样人们就可以睡觉，不用听到它的声音，诸如此类的事情，你可以设置不同的时间表，当你出城时等等，如果你有Ecobee，这真的很好。在我们回到你的书之前，beestat.io，它会向你展示Ecobee的完整分析转储，它会告诉你为了将你的房子加热或冷却一度，它需要运行多长时间，室外温度是多少，它只是给你提供完整的
um i i installed it myself it was pretty easy and uh you could do things that are pretty pretty nice like for example um our heater is pretty loud and so it's it's pretty close to bedroom and so we'll do is we'll get the we'll run the heater a little bit earlier so that the house gets like pretty warm and then it doesn't need to run for a little while so people can sleep they don't have to hear it and just stuff like that that you can program different schedules put you're out of town all this stuff it's really nice if you have an ecobee before we go back to your book b stat b-e-e-s-t-a-t.io it'll show you like the full analytics dump of your ecobee and it'll like sort of tell you how long it has to be on in order to heat your house or cool your house by a degree outside temperature just gives you like the full
图表分解，显示你房子暖通空调系统背后的所有统计数据。哇，那太神奇了。那太酷了。是的，我得去看看。所以好的，所以智能恒温器太棒了。当时，很难打入那个市场。人们不认为普通人会想自己更换恒温器。房主自己更换恒温器是非常罕见的。他谈到了他们是如何着手的，你知道，他们包含了所有的工具。所以有这个，我想我还没买过Nest，但如果你买了，它会带一把这种花哨的螺丝刀。而且，你知道，他们考虑了所有不同类型的家庭恒温器设置。他们让你可以购买Nest。他在书中谈到的一个大问题是，让你购买Nest，而不必回到五金店，甚至不必去五金店。
graph breakdown of like all the stats underlying like your houses, your house's HVAC system. Whoa, that's amazing. That's super cool. Yeah, I'll have to check that out. So okay, so so so smart thermostat amazing. At the time, it was very hard to break into that market. People didn't think that ordinary people would want to replace their thermostat by themselves. It was very rare for a homeowner to replace their own thermostat. And he talks about kind of how they went about, you know, they include all the tools. So there's this like, I guess I haven't bought a Nest, but if you do, it comes with this fancy screwdriver. And, you know, like they've thought about all the different types of home thermostat setups you can have. And they've made it so that you can buy the Nest. One big thing he talks about in the book is making it so you can buy the Nest and not have to go back to the hardware store or even go to a hardware store.
你知道，只要去百思买（Best Buy），你就能买到Nest，并且拥有更换恒温器所需的一切，而无需任何专业知识或工具。我觉得这很聪明。所以，是的，这本书充满了这些聪明的管理见解。我得说，在缺点方面，我觉得这本书非常教条，当背后没有大量研究支持时，这并不好。例如，如果你读哈佛商业评论的书，它们会很教条。他们会说，哦，你应该尝试这样管理，你应该遵循这些规则。但这是基于我们策划的庞大数据集。我们采访了无数经理，我们决定这样做。这本书相当教条。它告诉你
You know, just go to Best Buy, you get the Nest and you have everything you need to replace your thermostat without needing any expertise or tools or anything. I thought that was clever. And so, yeah, the book is full of these clever kind of product management insights. I will say on the downside, I felt like the book was very prescriptive, which is not good when there's not a lot of research behind it. So, for example, if you read a book by Harvard Business Review, they'll be prescriptive. They'll say, oh, you should try and manage in this way, and you should follow these rules. But it's based on this huge data set that we curated. We interviewed a zillion managers, and we decided to do this. This book's pretty prescriptive. It tells
很多Tony认为你应该做和不应该做的事情，但没有任何数据支持这些。这只是他自己的轶事经验。所以，对这些建议要持保留态度。但我认为这些故事非常有趣，我从中受益匪浅。我想知道这里是否有一些想法
you a lot that Tony thinks that you should and shouldn't do, but there's no data backing any of that up. It's just his own anecdotal experience. And so take the prescriptions with a pinch of salt. But I felt like the stories were really interesting and I learned a lot from that. I wonder if there's some thought there
如果通过某种方式行事或以某种方式经营你的企业能获得某种优势，撇开你个人的道德和愿望不谈，如果它变得足够普遍，以至于可以在哈佛商业评论之类的论文中被捕捉并证明有效，它是否已经失去了优势？我想我几乎认为，如果每个人都做同样的事情，你就失去了作为独特文化的优势。所以并不是说你……如果你拥有一种特定的人想要加入并趋之若鹜的文化，但每个人都提供这种文化，你就必须为之进行更激烈的竞争。所以如果你提供某种在某种程度上反文化的东西，或者与平均水平相反的东西，
where like if you do something, if there's some edge to be had by acting in a certain way or running your business in a certain way, leaving sort of ethics in your own personal desire to do it, if it becomes prevalent enough to be captured and shown to work in a Harvard Business Review kind of paper, has it lost its edge? I guess I kind of almost see it as if everyone does the same thing, you lose the advantage of being a unique culture. So it's not that you're... If you have a culture that specific people want to come to and flock, but then everybody offers it, you have to compete a lot harder for it. So if you offer something almost counterculture in a way or counter the average,
你会吸引人们。现在，我不知道这些人是好是坏，但如果你找到一个能吸引志同道合的人，就会有更多的共识，你知道，团队成员之间的摩擦会少得多，你可以策划并继续前进。但如果它变成了，每个人都认为那是做生意的正确方式，而你不去质疑它。然后，就像你在这一领域有更多的竞争一样。
you'll attract people. Now, I don't know if those people will be good or bad, but if you find one that attracts people like-minded, there's a lot more agreement, you know, a lot less, you know, friction between team members and you can kind of curate that and go. But if it becomes, everybody believes that's the right way to do business and you don't question it. And then like you have a lot more competition in this space.
所以我认为著名的是，我的意思是，我认为Tony是在苹果公司的一种体制下成长起来的，这种体制对企业的经营方式非常有主见。所以他看到了它的成功，至少是轶事上的成功，然后去做了同样的事情。而且，我的意思是，你不能争辩说他所做的事情不是，我多少说他被收购了。他，你知道，Nest产品今天在许多人的家中。所以，同意或不同意他们。我想它确实奏效了。是的，我的意思是，你知道，你所描述的一个很好的例子是，嗯，我不想发誓这个例子有，所以有，有一种东西叫做“三明治法”（S sandwich），你可以猜出S是什么。所以通用电气的杰克·韦尔奇在他的书中普及了三明治法。
So I think famously, I mean, I think Tony came up in a regime at Apple that like was very opinionated in how businesses should be run. So he saw it be successful, at least anecdotally, and went and did the same. And I mean, you can't argue that what he did wasn't, I somewhat say he got acquired. He, you know, the Nest products are in many people's homes today. So, uh, agree or disagree with them. I guess it did work. Yeah. I mean, you know, a good example of what you described is, um, I don't want to swear that the example has the, so there's, there's something called the S sandwich and you can guess what S is. And so Jack Welch from GE, in his book, he popularized the S sandwich.
这个想法是你用两片面包。你说一些话。所以想象一下，你有一个一对一的会议，你必须告诉某人他们被降职了。所以他们会进来。你会说一些非常好的话。那是第一片面包。你会告诉他们他们被降职了。那会进来，你会说一些非常好的话。那是第一片面包。你会告诉他们他们被降职了。那是三明治的肉。然后你会以一些非常好的话结束，比如，你知道，嘿，你知道，奖金今年更高
And the idea is you have two slices of bread. You say something. So imagine you have a one-on-one where you have to tell someone that they're getting demoted. So they would come in. You would say something really nice. That's the first layer of bread. You would tell them they're getting demoted. That's would come in, you would say something really nice. That's the first layer of bread. You would tell them they're getting demoted. That's the meat of the sandwich. And then you would end with something really nice, like, you know, hey, you know, bonuses are bigger
之类的。所以这就是三明治法。在他的书中，他说，哦，你知道，他这样做非常成功，他有点像给人们抹黄油，告诉他们坏消息，以好消息结束，每个人都很高兴，所以，在《艰难的抉择》（The Hard Thing About Hard Things）中，他们谈到了三明治法对高级人员根本不起作用，因为现在已经是10、15年后了，每个人都知道，如果你开始说好话，那就是三明治法，或者无论人们变得多么愤世嫉俗，他们说如果是一个刚从大学毕业的初级人员，你可能会尝试，但不要再尝试了，所以这是你的观点，你有一种通信战术的军备竞赛，所以是的，如果你只是遵循别人说的
this year or something. And so that's the S sandwich. And in his book, he says, oh, you know, he does that and so successful and he kind of butters people up, tells them the bad news, ends on a good note and everyone's so happy so so then in um the hard thing about hard things um they talked about how the the s sandwich just doesn't work on senior people because it's it's now like 10 15 years later and everyone's everyone just knows like if you start saying something nice it's the s sandwich or whatever people just become cynical and they were saying how like if it's a junior person like straight out of college you might try it but don't try it anymore so it's it's your point you have this sort of arms race of communication you know tactics and and so yeah if you just follow what somebody said
对他们有效，你知道，也许5年前，今天可能就不起作用了。我觉得这里还有一条关于埃隆·马斯克经营公司哲学的旁路，我想，但我不知道，我们最好，我们最好继续前进。天哪。是的。那会，是的。我们时间不多了。是的。我的书是《Age of Myth》。这是一本关于一个虚构地方的虚构书，涉及精灵和人类。
worked for them you know maybe 5 years ago, it might not work today. I feel like there's a whole, a whole side route here about Elon Musk's philosophy on running companies as well, I think, but I don't, we better, we better keep moving. Oh my gosh. Yeah. That would, yeah. We're running low on time here. Yeah. My book is age of myth. This is a nice fictional book about a fictional place involving elves and humans.
三明治法中的虚构经理。不，不。所以《Age of Myth》是Michael Sullivan写的一本奇幻书。它与《Riyria Chronicles》在同一个宇宙中，但我相信设定在几千年前。所以它实际上不是前传，因为可能，我猜，有一些彩蛋或什么的指向后来的《Riyria Chronicles》。但如果你没读过它们，你可以读这本书。它基本上是独立的。我现在读了这本书的大部分了，它非常令人愉快，
A fictional manager in the S sandwich. No, no. So Age of Myth is a fantasy book by Michael Sullivan. It is in the same universe as the Rhaera Chronicles, but set, I believe, several thousand years before. So it actually isn't a prequel in that there maybe, I guess, are some Easter eggs or something to the later Rhaera Chronicles. But if you haven't read them, you can read this book. It sort of sits as independent. And I'm about most of the way through the book now. It's pretty enjoyable,
尽管我读过《Riyria Chronicles》，回来读这个，只是探索在另一本书中你已经存在、已经发生的一些世界，这很有趣。在这里，你几乎是在阅读后来成为历史的第一手资料。这是一种有趣的二分法，但作为一本书，它也是精灵和人类之间建立的一种有趣的张力，精灵在某种程度上被人类视为神话般永不死亡的神，而人类被精灵分开，被视为基本上是动物，结果发现这些都不是真的，精灵确实活得，你知道，基本上永远，但他们不能被杀死，他们可以，你知道，伤害自己并死亡，只是他们不会死于自然原因，所以，你知道
even though I have read the Rhaera Chronicles, coming back and reading this, just exploring sort of interestingly some of the world that you in the other book is just already there, already taken place. And here you're sort of almost reading like the firsthand account of what ends up being history later on. This is kind of an interesting dichotomy, but also just as a book, it's a sort of interesting tension that's built up between elves which are somewhat treated as like these mythically never die gods by humans and humans who are kept separate and seen as like basically animals by the elves only it turns out none of that is true like the elves do live you know for basically forever but they can't be killed they can you know hurt themselves and die it's just they don't die of natural causes so uh you know
这只是人类，我不想剧透，但基本上，你最终会得到那里的张力，结果发现人类并不是那些什么都不知道且极其原始的动物，他们可以交流和合作，所以这只是，不是通常的套路，也不是通常的套路，所以这是一本，我猜，像舒适奇幻书。所以也不是一本很难读的书。那么精灵和人类，他们是主角和反派吗？还是有其他他们在战斗的东西？不完全是。
it's just humans kind of i don't want to spoil but basically like you end up with the tension there and it turns out humans aren't these animals that know nothing and are ultra primitive like they can communicate and work together uh and so it's just uh not the normal trope but not not the normal trope either so it's a a good, I guess, like comfort fantasy. So not a super hard read either. So are the elves and the humans, are they the pro and antagonists? Or is there something else that they're fighting? Not exactly.
我认为这有点像双方内部都有张力。他们被迫以导致，双方内部都有张力，他们被迫以导致，故事弧线中积累的方式进行互动。所以，精灵亚文化如何相互关联的内部政治中存在一个问题。然后一些人类被卷入其中，精灵们被激怒了，
I think it's sort of like there's tension within both sides. And they're like forced to interact in ways that leads to the sort of like there's tension within both sides and they're like interact, forced to interact in ways that leads to the, the sort of buildup in the story arc. So there's, there's a problem in sort of the internal politics of how the elves like subcultures relate to each other. And then some humans get tied up into it and the elves get pissed off and
想要去做点什么。但并非所有的精灵都同意应该做什么，所以你最终会陷入一种，这听起来很糟糕，就像你不想读它一样，像政治，我认为这实际上我真的很感兴趣，某种政治斗争，或者至少这就是我读到的部分，或者听起来有点像《权力的游戏》的情况，有一点点，所以你知道，精灵有非常高的文化，你知道，他们关心的事情与人类不同。但人类也有拥有自己文化的小镇，你知道，谁将成为酋长，这是由，你知道，一场战斗决定的，你知道，那并不总是像你想象的那样发展。所以，你知道，两者之间有很大的区别，但是，你知道，差异比相同点多。太酷了。是的，我得去看看。酷。是的。
want to go do something about it. But not all the elves agree on like sort of what should be done and so you end up in sort of a well that makes it sound terrible like you don't want to read it though like a political i think it's actually i'm really intrigued political battle of sorts or at least that's how i the part i read from it or it sounds kind of like a game of thrones type situation a little bit a little bit so you know elves have like a very high culture and you know they are concerned about sort of different stuff than humans. But humans also have towns with their own culture and, you know, who's going to be chief and it's decided by, you know, a fight and, you know, that doesn't always go the way you think it's going to go. And so, you know, there's kind of a big difference between how the two, but, you know, the differences are more same than different. Very cool. Yeah, I'm going to check that out. Cool. Yes.
所以我们可以跳到本期工具。我的工具是Neon。早些时候我有一个工具，实际上我们请他们上了节目，PlanetScale，这是一个在云端运行的MySQL数据库。PlanetScale的一个非常不同的地方是，你基本上是在与其他人共享计算资源。所以它把成本降得很低。
So we can jump to tool of the show. My tool of the show is Neon. So earlier I had a tool of the show called, actually we had them on the show, PlanetScale, which is a MySQL database that runs out in the cloud. And one thing that's very different about PlanetScale is you're basically kind of sharing compute resources with other people. And so it drives the costs way down.
这是一个完全无服务器的MySQL。你不需要担心机器死机之类的，甚至不需要担心配置多少台机器，它会自动为你扩展。这是同样的东西，但用Postgres代替MySQL。所以它是一个完全无服务器的Postgres数据库。所以你可以做的是，想象你在电脑上构建一个简单的应用程序或网站。你在本地有一个Postgres数据库，你连接到它，写入一些数据。看起来不错。你可以免费设置一个Neon账户，你就会得到一个数据库，它会一直存在，他们会处理所有的正常运行时间和一切。我只是喜欢这种模式。
It's a totally serverless MySQL. You don't have to worry about the machine dying or anything like that, or even how many machines to provision, it just scales up for you. This is the same kind of thing, but with Postgres instead of MySQL. So it's a totally serverless Postgres database. And so what you can do, imagine you build a simple app or a website on your computer. You have a Postgres database locally and you connect to it, write some data. It's looking good. You can just set up a Neon account for free and you get a database and it'll just always be there and they'll handle all the uptime and everything. I just love this model.
我认为对于数据库，特别是对于副项目和那些不会使用大量计算的东西，这些东西工作得非常好。我喜欢拥有一个完全免费的副项目，我不需要继续付费。每次我每个月收到账单时，我说，哦，这是一个我从未完成的副项目，对吧？这是一个让事情起步，让你的想法起步的好方法，
I think for databases in particular, especially for side projects and things that aren't going to use a lot of compute, these things work really, really well. I love the idea of having a side project that's totally free, that I don't have to continue to pay for. And every time I get the check every month, I say, oh, this is a side project that I never finished, right? This is a great way to just get something off the ground, to get your idea off the ground
并且能够向任何人展示它而无需支付任何费用。所以，你知道，我认为如果它确实起飞了，如果你有那种Slashdot效应，那么你以后总是可以购买服务器等等，或者只是，你知道，利用灵活性。太棒了。我认为现在让人们更容易接触到这些新技术和方法
and be able to show it to anybody without paying any money. So, you know, and I think then if it does take off, if you have that slash dot effect, then you can always like buy servers and all of that later or just, you know, take advantage of the flexibility. Awesome. I think there's a lot of it's being made a lot easier to kind of to get on to these these new technologies and approaches
而且我很兴奋，我需要回到制作副项目，开始制作副项目。好的，我的是一个游戏，它可以在很多平台上使用，它实际上已经出来一段时间了，《7 Billion Humans》，我们之前谈过，这是一个Zachtronics游戏，我们之前谈过，它可以在很多平台上使用。它实际上已经出来一段时间了，《7 Billion Humans》。我们之前谈过，这是一个Zachtronics游戏，我们之前谈过其中的几个游戏，包括《Human Resource Machine》。我想是这样。或者《Human Resource Corporation》。
and i i'm enthused i need to get back into making side projects start making side projects nice uh mine is a is a game it's available on um on many platforms it's actually been out for a while seven billion humans we've talked before about uh this is a zachtronics game we talked before It's available on many platforms. It's actually been out for a while, 7 Billion Humans. We've talked before about, this is a Zachtronics game, we talked before about several of those games, including Human Resource Machine. I think so. Or Human Resource Corporation.
我想是Machine。但基本上，这两个都是视觉编程游戏，它们有一种非常有趣的动画风格。在《Human Resource Machine》中，你控制一个人并试图在办公室完成各种任务。这一次，你实际上是在控制一大群人，并试图在办公室完成各种任务。起初，我，我不知道，这看起来有点复杂，但后来我非常投入。
I think Machine. But basically, both of these are visual programming games where they have a very fun animated style. And in Human Resource Machine, you are controlling a person and trying to accomplish various tasks in the office. This time, you're actually controlling a whole bunch of humans and attempting to accomplish various tasks in the office. And at first, I was, I don't know, this just seems like a little bit more complicated, but then I got pretty into it.
而且它实际上非常有趣，因为他们开始引入你可以用许多人做的事情，比如你如何在不重复同样事情的情况下完成某事，也就是并发，以及他们给你什么样的并发控制？哦不，不会有互斥锁和信号量。就像，嗯，我的意思是，如果你想那样思考，他们给了他们的等价物。但如果你只是想把它当作一个游戏来玩，它也同样有效。而且我会
And it's actually very interesting because they begin to introduce things you can with many humans, like how do you accomplish something without like reduplicating the same thing, AKA concurrency and what kind of concurrency controls they give you? Oh no, there's not gonna be mutexes and semaphores. It's like, well, I mean, they give their equivalence of them if you want to think about that way. But if you just want to play it as a game, it works as well. And I will
说在两个游戏中，都有非常残酷的侧面挑战，你试图限制你使用的指令数量或尝试快速完成它。我没有玩那些，因为我在其中几个上尝试过。这就像我试图写一个非常优化的解决方案，非常紧凑。我得到了10条指令，它会弹出来，就像，你可以在四条内完成。就像，什么？不，什么？就像，我显然错过了一些东西。
say that in both games, there are very brutal side challenges where you attempt to limit the number of instructions you use or to try to accomplish it fast. And I'm not playing with those because I attempted to do it on a few of them. And it's something like I tried to write a really optimal solution, very compact. And I got like 10 instructions and it'll pop up and it's like, you could do it in four. And it's like, what? No, what? And it's like, I'm clearly missing something.
或者你平均在70秒内完成了它，而你应该在30秒内完成。就像，好的，我不知道。也许答案是硬编码整个东西。我不知道。但这是一种有趣的游戏，几乎是一种选择你自己的难度级别。虽然我会说，如果你是一个程序员，可能像，我想是可以完成的，我还没有完成《7 Billion Humans》，但你知道，可能需要很多时间，可能会失去你的兴趣。
Or you completed it in 70 seconds on average and you were supposed to do it in 30. And it's like, okay, I don't know. Maybe the answer is like hard coding an entire thing. I don't know. But it's kind of a fun game that's almost a choose-your-own-difficulty level. Although I will say, if you're a programmer, probably like, I think accomplishable i haven't finished seven billion humans yet but you know could take a lot of time may lose your interest
这很公平，如果你不是程序员，我可以看到难度是，我会，我会很乐意找到一个不是程序员的人，他完成了游戏的大部分或全部，并了解他们的背景，因为我认为你绝对可以参与其中并获得乐趣，我认为你可以完成它，但如果你这样做，你会学到很多编程知识。是的，完全正确。是的，我玩过这两个。第一个，《Human Resource Machine》，我能够相当快地通过它，完成所有的成就，并把它搞定。
that's fair if you're not a programmer i could see the difficulty being uh i would i would love to find someone who's not a programmer who made it most or all the way uh through the game and sort of understand about their background because i think you could definitely engage with it and be fun and i think you could accomplish it but you would learn a lot of programming along the way if you did. Yeah, totally. Yeah, I played both of these. And the first one, the human resource machine, I was able to pretty much blitz through it, do all the achievements and just knock it out.
而且就像，有几个，比如一些，你知道，在最难的关卡上使用最少的指令。这实际上花了我几个小时来真正思考，比如，哦，我到底该怎么做？比如六条指令。所以我真的必须思考它。但我最终通过了它。《7 Billion Humans》，我的意思是，其中一些简直难得不可思议。我认为问题在于，我仍然没有，你知道，
And it was like, there was a couple of them, like some of the, you know, use the smallest number of instructions on the very hardest levels. It actually took me hours to really think about like, oh, how the heck am I going to do this? Like six instructions. And so I really had to think about it. But I eventually got my way through it. The seven billion humans, I mean, some of those are just incredibly difficult. I think the problem is, and I still haven't, you know,
获得所有的成就。我认为问题在于，一旦你开始引入许多人，那么一些事情就会变成统计学的。例如，我特别想到一个，你有很多人，你必须，我想只是像加到一个块之类的。比如如果块小于10，那么加倍它之类的。但有许多块都需要加倍。为了用最少的指令完成它，你基本上必须让所有这些人进行随机游走。
gotten like the achievements, all the achievements yet. I think the problem is, once you start introducing many people, then some of the things become statistical. Like, for example, there was one in particular, I'm thinking of where you had a bunch of people and you had to, I think it was just like add to a block or something. Like if the block is less than 10, then double it or something like that. But there were a bunch of blocks that all needed to be doubled. And to do it in the fewest number of instructions, you basically had to have all of these people do a random walk.
所以他们所有人只是随机移动。如果他们发现一个块，他们就加倍它。只是有些人会掉进坑里或被困在角落里等等。没关系。只要有足够多的人，你知道，
So all of them just moved randomly. And if they found a block, they doubled it. And just some of the people would fall into pits or get stuck in corners or whatever. That's fine. As long as like enough people, you know,
在那里覆盖它。所以作为一个工程师，这让你畏缩，因为你只是看着所有这些随机游走，但就像，这是在三条指令内完成它的唯一方法，或者无论它是什么，所以是的，这是一种非常非常不同的思考方式。是的，我想我确实得到了
we're there to cover it. And so as a, as a, as an engineer, it makes you cringe because you're just watching all these random walks, but like, it's the only way to do it in three instructions or whatever it is and so uh yeah it's a very very different way of thinking yeah i think i did get
其中一个，我还没有完成《7 Billion Humans》，但我做了一个我们说的，我只是实现为每个人随机走动，没有偏见，没有其他任何东西，然后我坐在那里看着试图完成关卡，我想，好的，这会奏效，但我不知道这需要多长时间。与其只是走开，我只是重新编码它来偏向，哦，我知道目标是在下半部分，所以偏向随机，你知道，先尝试向下走，然后再向上走，这使它快了两倍，我只是在优化我坐在那里看着这个愚蠢的游戏自己玩的能力，所以是的，这实际上是一个非凡的游戏，当人们，如果人们想了解什么，你会称那种技能为什么，我猜，我猜像算法
one of those i haven't finished somebody but i did one we were saying where i like just implemented as like everybody walks around randomly no bias no anything uh and then i sat there watching trying to finish the level i'm like okay this is going to work but i have no idea how long this is going to take and rather than just like walk away i just like recoded it to like bias that oh i know the goal is like on the lower half so bias the random to to you know try to go down first before going up which made it twice as fast and i was just optimizing for my ability to sit there and watch this stupid game play itself out so yeah it's a phenomenal game actually when people uh if people want to learn about what would what would you call that skill i guess i guess like algorithms
也许，或者只是，是的，快速解决问题的方法，我不确定，不确定那种技能到底是什么，我的意思是，它不是一种特定的语言或任何东西，但它是一种很好的技能来建立。好的，我想是时候了，我们问过ChatGPT给我们一个介绍吗？或者任何东西，但它是一种很好的技能来建立。好的，我想是时候了。我们问过ChatGPT给我们一个介绍吗？我试过了，但它一直说我们已达到容量。甚至连“我们已达到容量”的消息也使用ChatGPT来告诉我各种告诉我他们已达到容量的方法。天哪。我今天还没试过使用ChatGPT，但我觉得做一个好的开始方法是深入了解它是如何工作的，以及RLHF，人类反馈强化学习和所有这些东西。所以我可以简要概述ChatGPT是如何工作的以及它是如何产生的。然后我们可以深入探讨我们看到的酷东西，
maybe or just yeah ways of solving problems quickly i'm not sure not not sure exactly what the skill is i mean it's not a particular language or anything but it's a great skill to build up all right i think it's time did we ask chat gpt to uh give us an or anything, but it's a great skill to build up. All right. I think it's time. Did we ask ChatGPT to give us an intro? I tried, but it just keeps saying we're at capacity. Only even the we're at capacity message uses ChatGP to tell me various ways of telling me they're at capacity. Oh, my gosh. I haven't tried using ChatGBT today, but I feel like a good way to do this is to start by diving into how it works and RLHF, Reinforcement Learning with Human Factors and all these things. So I can give kind of an overview of how ChatGBT works and how it came about. And then we can kind of dive into cool things we've seen,
对社会的各种影响等等。所以我们必须从理解语言模型开始，因为那是所有这一切的基础。所以语言模型，或者它也被称为前向语言模型，是你从维基百科获取一些文本，也许你只是从互联网上获取随机文本，然后掩盖它的一部分并尝试预测它，所以这是我们过去在节目中讨论过的，这被称为无监督或自监督学习，所以想法是，你知道，你可能会说“狗去了……”。
kind of implications for society and all of that. So we have to start with understanding language models because that's kind of the foundation for all of this. So a language model, or it's also called a forward language model, is where you take some text maybe from wikipedia maybe you have text just random text from the internet and you mask part of it and try and predict it so this is we've talked about this in past shows this is called unsupervised or self-supervised learning so the idea idea is, you know, you might say the dog went to the blank.
你知道，你可能知道，你可能有一个句子说“狗去了公园”，你把它替换为“狗去了……”，然后你要求你的机器学习模型填补那个空白。如果它填入“公园”，那就太棒了。而且它不是那种case语句。它是一个流动的过程。所以模型是从维基百科下载一大堆由人类编写的句子，但你可以使用所有这些人类写作来训练模型来完成人们的句子。所以你不需要任何人来创建任何特殊的标记数据。在某种意义上，他们已经通过
You know, you might know, you might have a sentence which says a dog went to the park and you replace that with the dog went to the blank and you ask your machine learning model to fill in that blank. If it fills it in with park, that's great. And it's not a sort of case statement like that. It's a fluid thing. So the model is download from Wikipedia a whole bunch of sentences that were written by humans, but you can just use all of that human writing to train a model to finish people's sentences. And so you don't need any humans to create any special labeled data. In a sense, they already have just by
在互联网上表达自己而拥有了，所以GPT实际上是一个非常大的模型，它有很多复杂性，但你把它看作一个大模型，你给它句子的一部分，它就会为你完成句子，然后你可以再次运行它，说，基于完成的句子，下一句的开头会是什么？它们可以跨越句子边界。它可以写段落。它可以跨越段落边界。
expressing themselves on on the internet so gpt is effectively a really large model there's a lot of complexity to it but you think of it as a large model where you give it part of a sentence and it will finish the the sentence for you and then And then you can run it again to say, based on the finished sentence, what would the start of the next sentence be? They can cross sentence boundaries. It could write paragraphs. It can cross paragraph boundaries.
所以它到了这样一个地步，你说，给出几个词来开启一个故事，它就会在你离开的地方继续，这就是语言模型。有没有一种方法，如果它太复杂或者我错过了，那没关系，但多年前你可以看到类似于你描述的这一部分的东西，比如你开始一个句子，你会得到其他东西，甚至只是要求某人生成合理的代码或合理的文本，它看起来比这里出来的要糟糕得多，而那些使用的是，我猜，我可能错过了，但查看维基百科或任何东西的语料库，并改变并说平均而言什么词开始一个句子，或者什么分布开始一个句子，什么词接下来出现，并构建
And so it gets to the point where you say, given a few words to kick off a story story it'll just continue where you left off that's a language model is there a way and if it's too complicated or if i missed it that's fine but years and years ago you could see something similar to this part you're describing where like you start a sentence and you would get something else or even just ask someone to generate plausible code or plausible text and it looked way worse than than what comes out here and those were using which i guess i and maybe i miss it but the look across a corpus of wikipedia or whatever and change and say what word on average starts a sentence or what distribution starts a sentence what word comes next and build the
所以这就到了这样一个地步：你给出几个词来开启一个故事，它就会从你中断的地方继续下去，这就是语言模型。有没有一种方法——如果太复杂或者我错过了也没关系——但多年前你就能看到类似于你所描述的部分，比如你开始一个句子，然后得到其他内容，或者只是让某人生成看似合理的代码或文本，但看起来比现在出来的东西差得多。那些使用的是——我想我可能错过了——查看维基百科或其他语料库，然后说平均来说什么词开启一个句子，或者什么分布开启一个句子，什么词紧随其后，并建立起……
in either word the sort of markov model stuff, like you move from each transition, each transition. And at some point you get a stop, right? And then you start again. Is there a fundamental difference between what that was doing and like what the setup is as sort of you described? Yeah. Yeah. And you kind of alluded to it. So I'll explain what Markovian is. So Markovian is a process where at any given place in the process, you don't need to think about the past. So for example, imagine chess. I could walk up to a chess board where the game is half over and that was played by somebody else and I can resume their game and it's not a problem. I don't need to ask that person what they were thinking. I might help, but I could just start playing that game and it's fine.
无论哪种马尔可夫模型，你都是从一个状态转移到另一个状态，不断转移。在某个点你会停下来，对吧？然后重新开始。这种做法和你描述的设置之间有什么根本区别吗？是的，你刚才提到了。我来解释一下什么是马尔可夫性。马尔可夫过程是指在过程中的任何给定点，你都不需要考虑过去。比如，想象一下国际象棋。我可以走到一个下到一半的棋盘前，那是别人下的，我可以接着他们的棋局继续下，这没问题。我不需要问那个人他在想什么。虽然问了可能有帮助，但我完全可以直接开始下，这没问题。
That's an example of a Markovian process. Chess is a Markovian game, so you don't need the history. Now, for example, let's say Monopoly where you're hiding your money. That is non-Markovian because if i jump into a middle of a monopoly game kind of need to know like who's been spending their money otherwise it's going to be really difficult right so the new models are transformer based and so the way that works is they build up a memory over time it's kind kind of like playing Monopoly where you know at the very beginning everyone started with $1,500. And so I know that, okay, this person's been spending a lot
这就是马尔可夫过程的一个例子。国际象棋是一个马尔可夫游戏，所以你不需要历史记录。现在，比如大富翁游戏，如果你在隐藏你的钱。那就是非马尔可夫的，因为如果我中途加入大富翁游戏，我需要知道谁一直在花钱，否则会非常困难，对吧？所以新的模型是基于Transformer的，它的工作方式是随着时间积累记忆，这有点像玩大富翁，你知道一开始每个人都有1500美元。所以我知道，好吧，这个人一直在花很多
of money, therefore they must have less money now. And so similarly, the transformers will, the encoders will keep track of everything that's happened. And typically this would not work because you would get just overwhelmed with the past. And it's very hard to know what things in the past are actually important. So you would just throw everything into some soup and then you would hope over time that the things that were important would stay in the soup, and the things that weren't important would be overwritten
钱，因此他们现在的钱一定变少了。同样地，Transformer的编码器会跟踪发生的一切。通常这行不通，因为你会淹没在过去的信息中。而且很难知道过去哪些事情是真正重要的。所以你只会把所有东西都扔进一个大杂烩里，然后希望随着时间的推移，重要的东西能留在汤里，而不重要的东西会被后来出现的东西覆盖
by things coming later, right? This became much easier with this thing called an attention mechanism. So the idea with attention mechanisms are when something goes into the memory, you actually provide a bias. You actually say like, I want this to go into the memory and it's really important. Or I want this to go into the memory and it's not very important. And there's even like a positional bias on top of that. And so, again, and let me say this bias, you're not putting this yourself. Like you're not saying this word is important as a designer of the model, but you're sort of like making it very easy for the model to learn. This is important. This isn't important because you're
，对吧？有了所谓的注意力机制，这就变得容易多了。注意力机制的理念是，当某些东西进入记忆时，你实际上提供了一个偏差。你实际上是在说，我想让这个进入记忆，它非常重要。或者我想让这个进入记忆，但它不太重要。甚至还有位置偏差。再说一次，让我说明一下这个偏差，不是你自己放进去的。作为模型的设计者，你并不是在说这个词很重要，而是你让模型更容易学习到这一点。这是重要的，那是不重要的，因为你
sort of giving that pathway. You're giving that lexicon and the model can can you know use that to to to learn attention versus having to to to do it otherwise is really hard uh so you don't influence it to say these like before you'd always hear about stop words or whatever words that just didn't mean mean much you don't teach it hey these words are low information english words you just say here's a mechanism for saying certain phrases or words are more important than others but that variable is left unset and then during training it attempts to figure out the values to set that that parameter to yeah exactly right exactly right and so right and so that was a big deal. There was a paper that came out from Facebook called Attention is All You Need, where effectively they showed that this attention part of the
提供了一条路径。你提供了词汇表，模型可以利用它来学习注意力，而不是必须以其他方式去做，那真的很难。所以你不会去影响它说，就像以前你总是听说停用词或其他没什么意义的词，你不需要教它“嘿，这些词是低信息量的英语词”，你只是说“这是一个让某些短语或词比其他词更重要的机制”，但那个变量是未设置的，然后在训练过程中，它会尝试找出该参数应该设置的值。是的，完全正确，完全正确。所以这是一个大事件。Facebook发表了一篇名为《注意力就是你所需要的一切》（Attention is All You Need）的论文，他们有效地证明了注意力部分
network was by far the most important. You'll see this a lot in academia where people just add things, add things, add things. They'll just continue to build, remix each other's work. And then at some point, no one's really clear what is actually causing this to be successful. And so the attention is all you need paper is really interesting where they tore everything down and they said, oh yeah, attention is actually by far the most important thing. Everything else is either less important or completely unimportant. That allowed people to refocus on attention. You started getting these stacked attention layers and all these other things. And that caused this huge explosion in accuracy and all of that. There's some other tricks. So another really cool trick is, you know, the model will output a probability. So it'll say, oh, you know, the next word could be dog,
是网络中迄今为止最重要的部分。你在学术界会经常看到这种情况，人们只是不断地添加东西。他们会继续构建，重混彼此的工作。然后在某个时候，没人真正清楚到底是什么导致了成功。所以《注意力就是你所需要的一切》这篇论文非常有趣，他们拆解了一切，说，哦，是的，注意力实际上是迄今为止最重要的东西。其他一切要么不那么重要，要么完全不重要。这让人们能够重新关注注意力。你开始得到这些堆叠的注意力层和所有其他东西。这导致了准确率的巨大爆炸式增长。还有一些其他技巧。另一个非常酷的技巧是，你知道，模型会输出一个概率。所以它会说，哦，你知道，下一个词可能是狗，
it could be cat, it could be fence, could be horse, like all of these are pretty likely. So let's say you pick dog. So now you try and generate the next word, and there's going to be a set of probabilities for that. And so you could almost think of this like a game tree, right? Like you're kind of searching. And so what you really want is not just the most probable word at every step, that's greedy, right? What you really want is a string of words where the sum or maybe the product of those probabilities is really high. So even though dog might be a really probable word, if you say dog, then like you can't really find another word afterwards that makes the sentence make sense. So you've kind of painted yourself in a corner. And so they actually, not only did they start doing beam search through all these probabilities, they actually created a differentiable beam search. So in other words, the neural network will actually get better at searching over time.
可能是猫，可能是栅栏，可能是马，这些可能性都很大。所以假设你选择了狗。现在你尝试生成下一个词，会有一组概率。所以你可以把这看作是一个博弈树，对吧？就像你在搜索一样。所以你真正想要的不仅仅是每一步最可能的词，那是贪婪算法，对吧？你真正想要的是一串词，它们的概率之和或乘积非常高。所以即使“狗”可能是一个很可能的词，如果你说了“狗”，那么你之后就很难找到另一个词让句子通顺了。所以你把自己逼进了死胡同。所以他们不仅开始在所有这些概率中进行束搜索（beam search），他们实际上还创建了一个可微的束搜索。换句话说，神经网络实际上会随着时间的推移在搜索方面变得更好。
And so you don't have to exhaustively search the whole space. So there's all these tricks. And when you layer them all together, you end up with something like extraordinarily powerful. And so GPT-3 is basically that forward language model joined with a query language model. So they have a language model for things GPT-3 can say. They have a language model for queries that a person could type in. And they join them together so that, you know, you type in your query, like, you know, write an article about, you know, interest rates or something. And so GPT-3 has seen a million queries.
所以你不必穷尽整个空间。所以有所有这些技巧。当你把它们层层叠加在一起时，你最终会得到一些非常强大的东西。所以GPT-3基本上就是那个前向语言模型加上一个查询语言模型。他们有一个用于GPT-3可以说的内容的语言模型。他们有一个用于人可以输入的查询的语言模型。他们把它们结合在一起，这样，你知道，你输入你的查询，比如，写一篇关于利率的文章之类的。所以GPT-3已经见过一百万个查询了。
It embeds that query you made into a certain space. And then it uses that space to start generating content. That sounds a lot like the front half of how I've heard DALI described, though. It's similar, right? Yeah. So DALI, you have the query text, just like you have with GPT, except instead of a text generation, you have an image generation. You have a variational autoencoder. But you're right.
它将你所做的查询嵌入到某个空间中。然后它利用那个空间开始生成内容。但这听起来很像我听到的DALI描述的前半部分。它很相似，对吧？是的。所以DALI，你有查询文本，就像GPT一样，只是它不是文本生成，而是图像生成。你有一个变分自编码器。但你是对的。
Yeah, the first part is exactly the same. Interesting. And then do they... Oh, okay. So they're taking building blocks, each of these building blocks, and then they're able to sort of like iterate by rolling forward in sort of a fashion by gluing these things together. Yep, yep. And so now the chat GPT, the thing they did there that is really interesting is this idea called reinforcement learning with human factors or RLHF. The intuition behind this is, you know, a GPT result is good if someone says it's good.
是的，第一部分完全一样。有趣。然后他们……哦，好的。所以他们正在采用构建块，每一个构建块，然后他们能够通过将这些东西粘合在一起，以某种方式向前滚动来迭代。是的，是的。所以现在ChatGPT，他们在那里做的非常有趣的事情是这个叫做“人类反馈强化学习”（RLHF）的想法。这背后的直觉是，你知道，如果有人说GPT的结果好，那它就是好的。
That's the premise. So what they'll do is they'll, then now this is where human raters come into play. They'll take like five results for the same query from GPT-3. So, you ask GPT-3, write an article about interest rates, you do that five times. All of these models are variational, which means that in addition to passing in the query, you also pass in a random set of numbers. And so every time you make a query, you're going to pass in a different random set of numbers, and you're going to get a different answer for that query. So they take five answers for the same query, they give it to a human, and they ask the human
这就是前提。所以他们会做的是，现在人类评估者登场了。他们会从GPT-3中获取同一个查询的五个结果。所以，你问GPT-3，写一篇关于利率的文章，你做五次。所有这些模型都是变分模型，这意味着除了输入查询外，你还输入了一组随机数。所以每次你进行查询时，你都会输入一组不同的随机数，并且你会得到该查询的不同答案。所以他们对同一个查询取五个答案，给一个人，然后让人
to rank the five answers based on their own personal preference. And so then they do something, this is going to get a little bit technical, but they do something called log gumbel or Frechet regression. So the idea is you have a ranked set. And so you don't know how much better the first one is than the second could be a little bit better it could be a lot better all you know is the pairwise differences like you know one is better than two two is better than three you don't know by how much and so if you do something simple like say i'm going to give five points number one four points number two etc you're going to get burned because you're assuming that that number one is i guess 20 better than number two, et cetera, you're going to get burned because you're assuming that that number one is,
根据他们自己的个人偏好对这五个答案进行排名。然后他们做了一些事情，这会变得有点技术性，但他们做了一些叫做Log-Gumbel或Frechet回归的事情。所以想法是你有一个排名的集合。你不知道第一个比第二个好多少，可能好一点，也可能好很多，你只知道成对的差异，比如你知道1比2好，2比3好，你不知道好多少。所以如果你做一些简单的事情，比如我说我要给第一名5分，第二名4分等等，你会吃亏的，因为你假设第一名比第二名好20%，等等，你会吃亏的，因为你假设第一名
I guess, 20% better than number two. And that assumption is not right. So what you do instead is there's this trick where, yeah, it's gets super technical, but basically you want to look at like, can I recreate the whole ordering? Like like can i train a model which given these five paragraphs returns you know three five four one two you know like returns the ordering that the human returns and so that's a chain of decisions and so there's there's this trick where the log gumball distribution you know from from we talked about this in the stats episode. If you take two like normally distributed numbers and you add them, the result is also normally distributed. And so that's a really nice property because you're not you don't have to add any information.
比第二名好20%。而这个假设是不对的。所以你取而代之的是有一个技巧，是的，这变得超级技术性，但基本上你想看看，我能重建整个排序吗？比如我能训练一个模型，给定这五个段落，返回3、5、4、1、2，你知道，返回人类返回的排序，所以这是一个决策链，所以有一个技巧，Log-Gumbel分布，你知道，我们在这个统计剧集中谈到过。如果你取两个正态分布的数字并将它们相加，结果也是正态分布的。这是一个非常好的属性，因为你不必添加任何信息。
It's like I have these two normally distributed numbers. You have a mean any information. It's like I have these two normally distributed numbers. You have a mean of three. I add them together. I get another normally distributed number with a mean of six. And so I don't have to keep track of what I did in the past. It's always like just another normal distribution, right? So what we figured out, we were at Facebook, we were trying to find something that could do that, but for multiplication. Is there a distribution where if I just multiply it by itself, by the same distribution with different parameters, that I get itself? Is there a distribution where I can do that? And there is one that looks close to the normal distribution.
就像我有这两个正态分布的数字。你有一个均值。我把它们加在一起。我得到另一个均值为6的正态分布数字。所以我不需要跟踪我过去做了什么。它总是就像另一个正态分布，对吧？所以我们弄清楚了，我们在Facebook时，我们试图找到能做到这一点的东西，但用于乘法。有没有一种分布，如果我只是用它自己乘以自己，用相同的分布但不同的参数，我得到它本身？有没有一种分布我可以那样做？确实有一种看起来很接近正态分布的分布。
Not perfect, but it's pretty close. And that's this log Gumball distribution. And so we took advantage of this trick where if I have a decision to make, like should I rank this item 1, 2, 3, 4, 5? And then based on that, should I rank the next item like 1, 2, 3, 4? And so you're chaining together all these decisions. You're multiplying all these decisions. And it's really convenient if at the end you just get one distribution.
不完美，但非常接近。这就是Log-Gumbel分布。所以我们利用了这个技巧，如果我有一个决定要做，比如我应该把这个项目排在1、2、3、4、5吗？然后基于此，我应该把下一个项目排在1、2、3、4吗？所以你把所有这些决定串联在一起。你把所有这些决定相乘。如果你最后只得到一个分布，那就非常方便了。
So log gumball is the sort of trick that lets us do that. So yeah, all of that to say there's a nice way to learn from those ranks that came from those people. So you give a million of these, you know, five tuples of answers to people on like Amazon, Mechanical Turk and these other rating facilities. They go in and rank them for you. And then you train a model off that. And so now what you get is the answers are heavily heavily biased towards things that people would want to read and that ends up having like a huge impact on the quality so it sounds like from what you said i know after dolly which i guess like isn't available for just
所以Log-Gumbel是让我们做到这一点的技巧。所以是的，所有这些都是为了说，有一种很好的方法可以从那些来自人们的排名中学习。所以你给亚马逊Mechanical Turk和其他评级机构的人提供一百万个这样的五元组答案。他们进去为你排名。然后你根据那个训练一个模型。所以现在你得到的是，答案被严重偏向于人们想读的东西，这最终对质量产生了巨大的影响。所以听起来从你说的，我知道在DALI之后，我想它对每个人来说都不可用，但稳定扩散（Stable Diffusion）类似的路径人们采取了，有一种引导版本会出现，它会给你一些东西。而且，从听你说的，就像我给了这组随机数，然后沿途做出了这些选择、概率等等。如果你说我想要更像这个的东西，比如拿这个，或者我想你甚至可以在DALI中做到这一点，比如这张图片，选择这个，我想要接近这个但有点不同的东西，听起来同样的机制在这里也有效，所以我们可以看到ChatGPT，比如如果你试图策划一个故事
everyone's use but the stable diffusion like the similar approach people kind of take, there was the like sort of guided version that would come out where like it would give you something. And I, from listening to what you said, it's like I gave this random set of numbers and then made these choices, probabilities, whatever along the way. And if you say I want something more like this one, like take this, or I guess you can even do that in Dahlia, like this picture, like choose this one and I want something close to this but a little bit different and it sounds like the same mechanisms would work here so we could see chat gbt where like if you were trying to curate a story
，它为你写了一个，你可以要求一个非常相似的，它就能为你产生一些非常相似的东西，而不是仅仅是其他随机的、与你的第一个毫无关系的东西。是的，那是对的。而且，是的，我不确定ChatGPT部分在什么时候介入，比如我不确定他们是在播种随机数，还是他们实际上根据人们的偏好重新训练了整个模型。他们在那方面可以走任何一条路。但是的，这基本上就是它的工作原理。所以酷的事情是，实际上，我们用这个结束技术部分。这里的新颖之处在于强化学习非常、非常慢。
and it wrote you one you could ask for one that's really similar and it could produce you something really similar as opposed to just something else random uh that had nothing to do with your first one yeah that's right and uh yeah i'm not sure at what point the chat gpt part comes in like like i'm not sure if they are seeding the random number or if they're actually retraining the entire model based on uh you know the people's preference They could go either way there. But yeah, that's basically how it works. And so the cool thing, actually, we'll finish the technical part with this. The novelty here is reinforcement learning is very, very slow.
它需要大量数据才能做任何事情。这就是为什么它非常适合像围棋这样的事情，机器可以在没有任何人在循环的情况下互相玩。但它在有……的地方真的很挣扎。你不会把它用于蛋白质折叠，除非你可以……好吧，实际上，你可以在模拟中做到这一点。什么是一个好的例子？如果你必须做一些化学测试，而一个穿着实验服的人必须做一个测试，你不会使用
It requires a lot of data to do anything. This is why it's really good for things like Go, where the machines can play each other without any human in the loop or anything. But it really struggles in things where there's... You wouldn't use it for protein folding unless you could... Well, actually, you could do that in simulation. What's a good example? If you had to do some chemical test, where a human actually in a lab coat had to do a test you wouldn't use
强化学习，因为它会花费太多时间，我们称之为样本效率低下。他们使用的技巧是，你知道，他们只在最后已经有了一个相当好的东西时才使用强化学习。因此，他们能够从每个例子中获得很多收益，这是一个非常有趣的新颖之处。哦，酷。所以是的，我想这就是它基本上是如何工作的，简而言之。而且人们一直在用它做各种疯狂的事情。你，你见过最疯狂的用途是什么，Patrick？或者最酷的，也许。是的，我的意思是，我见过各种各样的。
reinforcement learning for that because it would just take uh too too much time and it's we call this sample inefficient the trick that they used is you know they only used reinforcement learning at the very end when they already had something that was pretty good and so because of that um they were able to get a lot of bang out of every example um and that was a really interesting novelty oh cool so yeah i think uh that's that's basically how it works kind of in a nutshell and uh people have been using it for all sorts of of wild things have you what's the craziest use you've seen, Patrick? Or the coolest, maybe. Yeah, I mean, I've seen a variety.
我认为每个人都在说的那个是垃圾邮件生成。这是我一直看到的，就像……你收到过任何ChatGPT垃圾邮件吗？我不知道。我的意思是，我想这就是争论，对吧？就像，我们会知道吗？但这是我看到的，就像，有人需要生成很多变体，对吧？
I think the one that everyone keeps saying is sort of spam generation. That's the one that I keep seeing, which is like... Have you gotten any chat GPT spam? I don't know. I mean, I guess that's the debate, right? It's like, would we know or not? But that's the one that I see where it's like, someone needs to generate a lot of variations, right?
这正是垃圾邮件传统上不是的东西。也就是，嘿，我是某个国际王子，有很多钱，要寄给你。你只是把同样的东西发给一百万人。现在你把同样的想法发给一百万人，但每一个都是不同的。你不能写过滤词来试图把它留在你的垃圾邮件收件箱垃圾文件夹里。是的，我很惊讶那还没有
Which is what spam traditionally wasn't. Which is, hey, I'm a whatever international prince who's had a lot of money and gonna send it to you. You just send the same thing to a million people. Now you send the same idea to a million people, but each one is different. You can't write filter words to try to keep it in your spam inbox spam folder yeah i'm surprised that hasn't
发生，或者如果它发生了，Gmail仍在弄清楚如何阻止它。我想也许人们还不能像他们需要的那样批量生成它们。哦，对了，这是一个很好的观点。是的，我看到的最有趣的事情之一是人们用它在测试中作弊，比如，哦，不是测试，而是英语作业，比如写一篇关于毕加索的文章，他们只是告诉ChatGPT去做。我，你知道，我看到了很多。而且你猜它有道德影响，但我怀疑，如果那是你唯一需要写的东西，那还好。但大多数学生，我觉得你会很清楚那个学生过去是用这种声音写的。ChatGPT在目前的状态下很难生成一份看起来是用你的声音写的读书报告。是的，那是一个
happened yet or if it is gmail is still figuring out how to block it i think maybe people aren't able to generate like them in bulk in the way they would need to to do it quite yet oh right that's a good point yeah one of the most interesting i saw were people using it to cheat on on tests on like uh oh not tests but like on english homework like write an essay about picasso and they would just tell chat gpt to do it i you know i saw a lot of that and i you guess it has ethical implications, but I wonder, though, if that's the only thing you ever had to write, fine. But most students, I feel like you would know pretty well that the student used to write in this voice. It would be very difficult for ChatGPU in its current state to generate a book report that looks like it's in your voice yeah that's a
很好的观点。你知道，比如给我写一封C级的论文，因为我是个C级学生，也许我做不到，它现在被屏蔽了，但你知道，我不确定这看起来有点难，但我确实认为这是一个大问题，人们只会生成至少一个输入让他们开始，对吧？而不是做研究。是的，我的意思是，我想像什么能让这变得非常强大，如果你正在写，比如说，一封营销邮件或销售邮件，你想让ChatGPT写你写的变体。但后来，你知道，当我想的时候，就像，那里面有什么真正的价值？你知道，因为无论如何你都要把它发给
good point you know like write me a letter c a graded c paper because i'm a c student like i maybe i can't get it it's blocked right now but like you know i i'm not sure that that seems a bit hard but i do see this as like a big concern that people will just generate at least an input for them to start with, right? Rather than doing the research. Yeah, I mean, I would imagine like what could make this really powerful is if you were writing, let's say, a marketing email or a sales email and you wanted ChatGPT to write variants of what you wrote. But then, you know, if when I think about it, it's like, what's the real value in that? You know, because you're sending it
两个不同的人，或者也许实际上，哦，这就是它会是什么。如果你写，嘿，我想介绍我们的新产品。它叫，你知道，FUBAR安全。FUBAR安全比FOO安全好得多，有这五件事。所以你写了那个。然后你给ChatGPT关于你客户的信息。然后它为每个客户重写了它，就像，是的，就像，嘿，你知道，你的女儿会非常喜欢这个，因为，你知道，就像你知道这个人有个女儿。所以这可能会很疯狂。我认为我见过的酷用例，而且我认为它们和我说的类似，如果你要交一篇学期论文，你可能需要编辑和策划它所说的内容，我会争辩说，如果你能策划和编辑到它应该是什么样子，你可能一开始就能做到，如果你真的想的话。所以除了只是消耗一段时间之外，练习的意义是什么？就像，那是，无论如何，我要出去了。但是的，所以如果你能策划、编辑、
to two different people anyways, or maybe actually, oh, here's what it would be. It would be amazing if you wrote like, hey, I wanted to introduce our new product. It's called, you know, FUBAR security. FUBAR security is so much better
结合并更快地制作出一篇论文，这真的是个问题吗？就像你在展示对主题的理解。我会说类似的例子是，我们在假期剧集中提到了，但很多人使用Stack Overflow，你只会去问ChatGPT，我的代码有什么问题，或者我怎么做这个。我看到的几个经历过那个的人，它非常接近，但它通常也还不能完全工作。所以如果你问它，我怎么做，你知道，我想在Python中对PNG运行边缘检测过滤器，它就像，以前那会是一系列Stack Overflow查询，现在你会得到一些对于知道如何做的人来说80%完成的东西，只要有足够的时间。所以他们可以采用ChatGPT的输出，他们现在可能就像，哦，有这个OpenCV。什么是OpenCV？哦，它，哦，好的。然后，你知道，哦，它是这个调用，这就是它。你可能需要交换一些行，
than like FOO security has these five things. So you write that. Then you give chat GPT like information about your clients. And then it like rewrote it for each client, which is like, yeah, like, hey, you know, your daughter would really love this this because like, you know, it's like you knew that this person had a daughter. So like that could be wild. I think the cool use cases I've seen, and I think they're kind of similar to what I would say for the like, if you're going to turn in a term paper, you probably need to edit and curate down what it says, which I would argue if you can curate and edit down to like what's supposed to be, like, you probably could have done it in the first place had you really wanted. And so what was the point of the exercise other than to just like, consume an amount of time? Like, it's the that's the anyways, I'm gonna get outside. But yeah, so if you're able to like curate, edit,
但你有，你知道，初步近似，你有结构、步骤、库，甚至是函数调用。但它可能并没有完全按照你要求的那样做，要么是说明不足，要么就是没完全弄对。但对于一个可以坐下来写它，但可能不熟悉那种语言的人来说，你已经走得远多了。是的，这很有道理。很多人说这对谷歌搜索是一个巨大的威胁。我不太理解那个。你，你对那个有更好的把握吗？比如，这种生成式AI和谷歌搜索之间的联系是什么？我认为这是很多人去，所以很多人去谷歌并输入Facebook，对吧？所以他们把它用作导航。我不认为那是一个危险。我不认为那是一个危险。我不认为如果你在ChatGPT中输入Facebook，你会得到那个响应。对。是的。或者也许你会。
combine and produce a paper faster, like that really a problem like you're demonstrating like understanding of the subject and the similar one i would say is we we in a holiday episode we got brought up but like a lot of people stack overflow right you'll just go ask chat gpt instead what's wrong with my code or how do i make this and the few that i've seen go through that it it's eerily how close it gets but it normally also doesn't work quite yet so like if you ask it how do I do you know like I want to run an edge detection filter on a png in python and it's like before that would have been like a sequence of stack overflow queries now you're going to get something that's 80 of the way there for someone who would
但这并不有趣。我认为那里的威胁是谷歌已经尝试通过其侧面的知识栏所做的事情，在那里他们给你问题的答案而不需要你去网站，对吧？哦，我明白了。如果你输入什么电影有，有，我不知道演员的名字，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，是的，当然，谢谢，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥演过什么电影，或者他值多少钱，或者其他什么，对吧？而它所做的只是去抓取前几页，就像向你展示电影，但它并没有真正去那些页面，对吧？所以首先，问题是，谷歌从那些网站获得该信息，对那些网站有什么好处，
know how to do it given enough time. And so they can take the chat GPT output and they now have probably like, oh, there's this open CV. What is open CV? Oh, it's, oh, okay. And then, you know, oh, it's this call and this is it. And you may need to swap some lines around,
但现在谷歌没有把他们送到那些网站。问题一。问题二，就像现在ChatGPT，竞争对手更容易站出来对抗谷歌进行那种问答。哦，那有道理，有道理。你能问，ChatGPT的事实语料库是什么样的？你能问它人们的净资产吗？它会准确吗？第二部分更难。所以它可能理解联合杯（United Cup）作为一名演员，他们可能，合理的演员薪水范围或这个，那个，它给你完全正确的数字，当它已经不是一个很好的数字时，这很有趣。我想这会引出我确实看到的一些东西，
but you have the like, to the, you know, initial approximation, you have the structure, the steps, the libraries, even function calls. But it probably doesn't do exactly what you asked it for either underspecified or it just didn't get it quite right. But you're a lot way further along for someone who could sit down and write it, but just may not be familiar in that language. Yeah, that makes sense. A lot of people are saying that it's a big threat to google search i don't quite understand that do you do you have a better handle on that like what's the connection between
也就是几篇文章，包括来自Wolfram Alpha团队本身的文章，但说，嘿，ChatGPT，你应该看看把你正在做的事情连接到Wolfram Alpha，因为Wolfram Alpha说，让我们拿一堆硬事实，并尝试使它们容易被人类语言查询。所以像数学、时区、人口统计这样的事情。净资产可能在里面，也可能不在。我不知道。但像这样的事情，只是可以从权威来源辨别的事实，编译它们并使它们可访问。如果ChatGPT，你知道，理解它需要这个事实，并且它可以去从Wolfram Alpha权威地获取它，然后把它反馈到它的输出中，对吧？这就像这个边车东西。我不知道
this generative ai and google search i think it's the a lot of people go to so a lot of people go to google and type in facebook right uh so they use it as like a navigation i don't think that's a danger i don't think that's a danger. I don't think if you type Facebook to chat GPT, you get the response. Right. Yeah. Or maybe you do.
那在训练中是如何工作的，以及所有这些将如何进行。但这是他们可以使用的这种几乎是事实的数据库存储。在Wolfram Alpha网站上，他们正在说它将如何值得。也许那是回应，因为他们担心不可避免的事情。为什么我们还需要Wolfram Alpha？为什么我们还需要谷歌？他们正在阻止它。但我确实认为那是一个可能发生的有趣的配对。是的，你知道，这真的很迷人。
But that's not interesting. I think the threat there is what Google tried to already do by its sort of knowledge bar on the side where they give you answers to the questions without you going to the website, right? Oh, I see. If you type in what movies has has i don't know what's an actor's name leonardo dicaprio yeah sure there we go thank you leonardo dicaprio what movies has leonardo dicaprio been in or how much is he worth or whatever right and all he's doing is going and scraping the first few pages and like showing you the movies but it doesn't actually go to those pages right so first of all the question is like what was in it for those websites that google got that information
就像如果你，这很棘手，你可以，例如，你可以让，假设你有人进去，每次有一个事实，实际上进入了语料库，就像他们必须浏览整个维基百科，如果维基百科是一个语料库，并且对于每一个事实，用SQL查询替换它，ChatGPT会学会偶尔进入SQL，然后跳出来。那会非常棒。而且这完全可行。我想，呃，
from them but now google doesn't send them to those websites problem number one problem two is like now chat gpt it is more easy for a competitor to stand up against google for that kind of question and answer oh that makes sense makes sense. Can you ask, what's like chat GPT's fact corpus like? Can you ask it people's net worth? Will it be accurate? The second part is harder. So it probably understands the United Cup as an actor, and they probably, plausible actor ranges of salary or this, that it gives you exactly the right number when it's already not a great number is interesting. I guess that'll lead to something that I did see,
是的，那可能是我们接下来看到的。哦，现在我们在给他们点子了。我只是不知道。呃，你忘了在最后尖叫商标了。我想困难的部分是，
which is several articles, including from the Wolfram Alpha team themselves, but saying that, hey, ChatGPT, you should look at like hooking up what you're doing to Wolfram Alpha because Wolfram Alpha says, let's take a bunch of like hard facts and try to make them easily
呃，是，是策划部分。所以你必须，你知道，要么编写算法，要么手工，你必须用查询来替换所有那些数据片段以检索它。是的，我想知道是否有某种方法可以在隔离中更直接地做到这一点。比如，教系统的一部分，嘿，这些类型的事情
queryable by roughly human language. So things like math, things like time zones, population statistics. Net worths may or may not be in there. I don't know. But things like that, which are just facts discernible from authoritative sources, compile them and make them accessible. If chat GPT sort of like, understood it needed this fact, and it could go and get it authoritatively from Wolfram Alpha and then feed it back into its output, right? It's like this sidecar thing. I don't
在这里是可以回答的。然后就像你说的，这是一个后续步骤。早期阶段说，嘿，插入代表我知道这是一个事实的标记，比如美元数量，对吧？
know how that works in the training and the like how all that would go. But it's this sort of almost database storage of facts that they could use. And there was on Wolfram Alpha site, they were sort of saying how like it would merit. Maybe that's in response because they were worried from the inevitable. Why do we need Wolfram Alpha anymore? Why do we need Google anymore? And they were heading it off. But I did think that was an interesting pairing that could happen. Yeah, you know, this is really fascinating.
美元数量。然后系统的第二部分可以理解，好的，它在寻找美元数量。我在这里看到薪水，然后系统的第二部分可以理解，好的，它在寻找美元数量。我在这里看到薪水，我看到一个演员的名字，因此，就像我需要点击这个系统来根据上下文填充那个标记的空白，对吧，对吧，对吧？这看起来完全可行。你知道，你甚至可以自动化很多这个，比如你可以，你可以，例如净资产，比如你可以手工做这个。比如，你可以，例如净资产。比如你可以手工进去说，
Like if you, this is tricky, you could for example like you could have let's say you had humans go in and every time there was a fact actually went in the corpus like they'd have to go through all of wikipedia if wikipedia is a corpus and for every fact replace it with a sequel query chat gpt would learn to like occasionally drop into SQL and then drop back out. That would be pretty freaking awesome. And it's totally doable. I think, uh,
每次你看到某人的净资产，用一些意味着对这个数据库的SQL查询的特殊标记替换美元金额。哦，然后开始训练模型自己做替换，然后提高准确性，从那里开始。哦，另一件事我应该提到的是，有一件事被低估了，但我知道，从，我确实认识OpenAI的一些人，他们说花费了大量时间
yeah, that might be what we see next. Oh, now we're giving them ideas. I just don't know. Uh, you forgot to scream trademark at the end. I think the hard part is,
在策划数据上。所以，你知道，有很多坏数据。有些东西会混淆算法。我的意思是，你知道，人们谈论很多错误信息，那有点不同，那是你知道有人故意说错误的事情，但他们可能说得非常雄辩，或者其他什么，但这只是，你知道，维基百科的部分内容只是搞砸了你的训练之类的，所以你知道人们认为，就像，哦，你知道，最终会有像一百万个开源ChatGPT，但除了电力成本和所有训练模型的成本之外，仅就人类劳动时间而言，数据策划是非凡的，人们并不真正知道这一点，或者他们认为这是
uh, is, is the curation part. So you would have to, you know to either write algorithms or by hand, you'd have to replace all of those pieces of data with queries to retrieve it. Yeah, I wonder if there's some way to do it more directly in isolation. Like, say, teach a portion of the system, hey, these kinds of things
理所当然的。是的，我认为那是，你知道，过渡，我猜从用途到展望未来，我认为这是那些事情之一，哦，我们要，你知道，它在这里，矩阵，我们都要被吸进去为ChatGPT提供动力，通过，就像，无论什么，我认为那里仍然有很多在清理数据的方式和你在哪里做的地方引入的人类偏见，以及很多人类努力，那会永远存在吗？不，可能不会，但我认为即使是维基百科风格本身也有很多选择，作为一个像那样的大语料库，比正常情况更标准化，然后我认为有很多东西进入了那个，嗯，然后保持它的新鲜。但我还认为他们会在那方面取得进展。
are answerable here. And then like either, like you were saying, it's like a follow-up step. The earlier stage says, hey, insert token that represents, I know this is a fact, like number of dollars, right?
它会变得更好。对我来说有趣的是，现在，你可以上网，去维基百科，无论什么，并把这些东西拉进来。你几乎需要维基百科在它出来之前的快照，因为现在当你谈论错误信息时，你开始进入我们可能看到的问题，也就是如果你只是通常在做网络爬取并寻找东西，这非常
Number of dollars. And then the second part of the system can understand, okay, it's looking for number of dollars. I see here salary then the second part of the system can understand okay it's looking for number of dollars i see here salary and i see a actor's name therefore like i need to hit this system to fill in the blank of that token based on the context right right right it seems totally doable you know you could even automate a lot of this like you could you could for example net worth like you could go in by hand of this. Like you could, for example, net worth. Like you could go in by hand and say,
直接，人们说，嘿，有人发了一篇文章说Jason Gauci实际上是一个外星人。而你对此感到非常沮丧。所以你想要关于你的其他文章出现。所以现在你不需要手写很多文章，你承担了很多幽灵笔名，无论什么，你写文章用类似或惨淡的信息淹没它，所以搜索不能再那样做了。而谷歌通常会有很多过滤策略，部分包括词语的质量。但现在那部分，那个信号消失了，他们将不得不回落到其他信号，但同时如果然后在某个
every time you see someone's net worth, replace the dollar amount with like some special token that means a SQL query to this database. Oh, and then start training the model to do the replacing itself and then get that accuracy up and go from there. Oh, another thing I should mention is one thing goes under rated, but I know from from I do know some folks at OpenAI and they said a ton of time
未来，你知道，公司或ChatGPT自己去网络并尝试消费由他们自己的工具生成的数据，那么就有这种整个，嘿，你真正得到的是什么？你得到的是你自己编造的信息，现在你把它作为真实事实反馈回去，所以，对，对，我认为这在未来很有趣。如果有人训练一个机器人用ChatGPT训练的维基百科文章来垃圾邮件维基百科，那会毁掉来源吗？哇，那太疯狂了。你知道，我一直像嘲笑那个，它叫什么，奇点，你知道，AI奇点和所有这些，但就像，但就像你可以接近一个点，AI，你知道，在网络上创建一堆内容，消费它，学习创建
is spent curating the data. So, you know, there's a lot of bad data. There's things which confuse the algorithm. I mean, you know, people talk a lot about misinformation that's a little different that's where you know someone's intentionally like saying the wrong thing but they could be saying it really eloquently or whatever but this is just like you know there's parts of wikipedia which just like mess up your training and stuff like that and so that you know people think like like uh like oh you know eventually there'll be just like a million open source chat gpts but beyond the electricity costs and all of that of training the model the data curation just in terms of human labor hours is extraordinary and people don't really know that or they take it
稍微不同的内容，实际上以某种奇怪的方式向前移动。哦，另一件与你所说的相关的事情，嗯，我注意到ChatGPT，他们放入了一些手工编码的答案。比如，如果你触及一些非常敏感的政治话题或对他们的业务来说只是危险的事情，他们并不真正想给出答案，它基本上会说由人类写的东西。他们这样做的方式是，他们只是把手工编码的答案放入排名系统，然后告诉人类排名者，或者只是强迫人类排名者总是给那个第一名分数。你做足够多次，现在你就有了一些可以远离非常微妙话题的东西。所以我认为他们那样做非常有趣。
for granted yeah i think that's the you know to transition i guess from uses into like looking forward i think that's one of those things where oh we're gonna you know it's here the matrix like we're all gonna get sucked into powering chat gpt by like whatever like i think the there is still a lot of human bias that gets introduced in like how you clean the data and where you do and a lot of human effort will that be forever no probably not but like i think there's a lot of selection even wikipedia style itself and being a big corpus like that that is more standardized than normal and then i think there's a lot that goes in into that um and then keeping it fresh. But I also think that they'll make progress on it.
是的，我认为OpenAI因为，我想，DALI以同样的方式受到了一些关注，比如试图避免某些事情，试图保持一种道德，我想，关于这个，并且，你知道，试图说，嘿，看，我们不希望这制造假新闻，或者你知道否认大屠杀，或者说这些已知的事情，但最终它也算是一种研究，一旦人们弄清楚它是怎么做的，它很昂贵，但人们可以重做它，对吧？人们会制作他们自己的版本，或者，你知道，我们看到了DALI，就像他们会做事情，他们不会，他们不会把那些限制放进去，所以这是一个有趣的游戏，关于这是否作为工具比研究更有用，或者在某种程度上它被完全关闭，没有学习发生，但你也没有道德担忧。你最终处于一个艰难的决策空间。
It'll get better. What will be interesting to me is right now, you can go onto the internet, go onto Wikipedia, whatever, and pull this stuff in. You almost need a snapshot of Wikipedia before it comes out because now you can start to get into the problems we could see when you're talking about misinformation, which is if you're just generally doing a web crawl and looking for things, it's very
它会变得更好。对我来说有趣的是，现在你可以上网，去维基百科或其他地方，把这些东西拉进来。你几乎需要维基百科在它发布之前的快照，因为现在当你谈论错误信息时，你可能会开始遇到问题，也就是说，如果你只是在进行常规的网络爬取并寻找东西，这非常……
straightforward for people to say like, hey, someone posted an article saying Jason Gauci is actually an alien. And you're very frustrated about that. So you want other articles about you to appear. So now rather than you having to handwrite many articles, you take on many ghost pen names, whatever, and you write articles that flood it with similar or dismal information, so searches can't do that anymore. And Google would normally have a lot of tactics for filtering that, in part including the quality of the words. But now that part, that signal goes away, and they'll have to fall back to other signals but at the same time if then at some
对人们来说很简单，比如，嘿，有人发了一篇文章说Jason Gauci其实是个外星人。你对此感到非常沮丧。所以你希望关于你的其他文章出现。因此，你不需要手写许多文章，而是使用许多化名，写一些文章用类似或糟糕的信息淹没它，这样搜索就无法再做到这一点了。谷歌通常会有很多过滤策略，部分包括词汇的质量。但现在那部分信号消失了，他们将不得不退回到其他信号，但与此同时，如果……
future you know company or chat gpt themselves goes to the web and tries to consume data that was generated by their own tooling then there's this whole like hey you're what are you really getting you're getting information that you made up and now you're feeding it back in as true facts and so right right i think there's this interesting going forward. If someone trains a bot to spam Wikipedia with chat GPT trained Wikipedia articles, does that ruin the source? Wow, that is wild. You know, I've always like laughed at the, what's it called the singularity, you know, AI singularity and all of that but like but like you could approach a point where where the ai you know creates a bunch of content on the web consumes it learns to create
未来，你知道，公司或ChatGPT本身去网络上尝试消费由他们自己的工具生成的数据，那么就会出现这种问题：嘿，你到底得到了什么？你得到的是你自己编造的信息，现在你又把它作为事实反馈回去。所以我认为未来会很有趣。如果有人训练一个机器人用ChatGPT训练的维基百科文章来向维基百科发送垃圾信息，那会毁掉这个来源吗？哇，这太疯狂了。你知道，我一直嘲笑所谓的奇点，你知道，人工智能奇点之类的，但你可能会接近一个点，人工智能在网上创造了一堆内容，消费它，学习创造……
slightly different content and actually kind of like moves forward in some weird way oh another thing related to what you said um i noticed with chat gpt they've they've put in some hand-coded answers. Like, for example, if you touch on some really sensitive political topics or things that are just dangerous to their business that they don't really want to give answers for, it'll basically say things that were written by a human. And the way they've done that is they've just put hand-coded answers into the ranking system and then told to the human rankers or just forced the human rankers to always give that the number one score. And you do that enough times and now you have something that can stay away from really delicate topics. So I thought that was really interesting the way they did that.
稍微不同的内容，并以某种奇怪的方式向前发展。哦，关于你说的另一件事，我注意到ChatGPT他们加入了一些人工编写的答案。例如，如果你触及一些非常敏感的政治话题，或者对他们的业务来说很危险、他们不想给出答案的事情，它基本上会说出由人类编写的内容。他们这样做的方法是，在排名系统中放入人工编写的答案，然后告诉人类评估员，或者强迫人类评估员总是给它打最高分。你这样做足够多次，现在你就拥有了一个可以远离非常微妙话题的东西。所以我认为他们这样做的方式非常有趣。
Yeah, I think Open AI has come under some interest for, I think, Dolly the same way, like trying to avoid certain things, trying to maintain a modicum of ethics, I would guess, about this and sort of, you know, try to say, hey, look, we don't want this making fake news or you know denying the holocaust or saying these things that are are known but ultimately it's also sort of research that once people figured out how it's done it's expensive but people can redo it right people will make their own versions or you know we saw that with dolly like they'll do things and they won't they won't put those restrictions in so it's a interesting game for like whether or not this this is more useful as a tool than research or whether at some level it's being completely closed and no learning taking place, but you also don't have the ethical concerns. You end up in a hard decision space.
是的，我认为OpenAI在Dolly上也受到了一些关注，比如试图避免某些事情，试图保持某种程度的道德，我想，关于这一点，试图说，嘿，看，我们不希望它制造假新闻，或者你知道，否认大屠杀，或者说这些已知的事情。但归根结底，这也是一种研究，一旦人们弄清楚了它是怎么做的，虽然昂贵，但人们可以重做，对吧？人们会制作他们自己的版本，或者你知道，我们在Dolly上看到了这一点，他们会做一些事情，而且他们不会加上那些限制。所以这是一个有趣的游戏，关于这作为工具是否比研究更有用，或者在某种程度上它是否完全封闭且没有学习发生，但你也没有道德方面的担忧。你最终会陷入一个艰难的决策空间。
Right. Yep. It's a really good call out. I think it's really interesting the fact that this is all private, like in the private sector where people have to worry about investors and all of that. And so, uh, and so the, the restrictions are going to be a really interesting space um there's some like you know unicorns already in this in this space the unicorns a company worth a billion dollars um there's some companies that are worth a billion dollars and they're literally just chat gpt uh like in a chrome extension or target targeted to a specific market or something like that so you, you know, I think it's like anything where, you know, there'll be a lot going on here, a lot of energy,
对。没错。这是一个非常好的切入点。我觉得很有意思的一点是，这一切都是私有的，比如在私营部门，人们必须担心投资者等等。所以，呃，所以这些限制将是一个非常有趣的领域。嗯，在这个领域已经有一些所谓的“独角兽”了，独角兽是指价值十亿美元的公司。有些公司价值十亿美元，而它们实际上只是把 ChatGPT 放在 Chrome 扩展程序中，或者针对特定市场等等。所以，你知道，我认为这就像任何事情一样，你知道，这里会有很多事情发生，会有很多活力。
and then we'll see sort of what rises to the top. But there's definitely like huge, huge value here. I mean, we have to, as a society, we have to figure out exactly where it belongs, but it's obvious that this is something really, really big. And the other thing that I wanted to highlight, it's not just for text and audio. I mean, look at that stable diffusion thing
然后我们会看到什么会脱颖而出。但这里绝对有巨大的价值。我的意思是，作为一个社会，我们必须弄清楚它到底属于哪里，但很明显，这是一件非常非常大的事情。我想强调的另一件事是，它不仅仅适用于文本和音频。我的意思是，看看那个 Stable Diffusion。
I talked about at the beginning of the show. You know, you could do this for just about anything. It can cross different media. I mean, video is a natural extension, but even to other sort of latent spaces like robotics. You know, imagine like a chat GPT where you tell a robot to pick up an arm, sorry, pick up an arm, pick up a block, tell a robot arm to pick up a block, and it turns that text into robotic motions.
我在节目开头提到的那个。你知道，你几乎可以用它做任何事情。它可以跨越不同的媒体。我的意思是，视频是一个自然的延伸，甚至可以延伸到其他潜在空间，比如机器人技术。你知道，想象一下像 ChatGPT 这样的东西，你告诉机器人拿起一只手臂，抱歉，拿起一只手臂，拿起一个积木，告诉机械臂拿起一个积木，它就会把这段文字转化为机器人的动作。
I mean, totally, totally plausible. So you tell robots like wave, like really vigorously or something. And it just knows what that means. That would be cool. I guess we should have made predictions for where we think this future is going. Yeah. What's your prediction? And then we'll call it a day. There will be a lot of articles by very angry teachers saying that like all their students do is ask chat GPT.
我的意思是，完全、完全可行。所以你告诉机器人像挥手一样，非常用力地挥手之类的。它就知道那是什么意思。那会很酷。我想我们应该对我们认为这个未来会走向何方做出预测。是的。你的预测是什么？然后我们就结束今天的节目。会有很多愤怒的老师写文章说，他们所有的学生只会问 ChatGPT。
I know that's already happening. Oh, wait, hang on. My prediction is I actually think robotics man i think robotics is a place where this kind of technology could be really disruptive in a good way i i would say i think memes i think we're gonna see a flood of memes out of this and people are gonna say are these funny one thing we yeah that's true one thing we don't have yet is something that can replace text in an image like imagine if you had something where there's like a speed limit sign and or like a traffic sign and you could change the text to say like like speed limit infinity as a joke and it would look like it really
我知道这已经发生了。哦，等等，等一下。我的预测是，我实际上认为机器人技术，伙计，我认为机器人技术是这种技术可能产生真正颠覆性影响的地方，而且是以一种好的方式。我会说，我认为模因，我认为我们将看到由此产生的模因浪潮，人们会问这些有趣吗？有一件事我们，是的，那是真的。有一件事我们还没有，那就是可以替换图像中文字的东西，比如想象一下，如果你有一个东西，上面有一个限速标志或者交通标志，你可以把文字改成“限速无限”作为玩笑，而且看起来它真的
belonged there you know like it would replace it appropriately yeah. And it would look like it really belonged there, you know, like it would replace it appropriately. Yeah, I think that feels like a little bit of a natural extension, but saying like, let me take a video of something and using not like we're seeing a lot of text, I think, but I wonder, and you were saying audio, that seems naturally just, but like,
属于那里，你知道，就像它会适当地替换它一样。是的。而且看起来它真的属于那里，你知道，就像它会适当地替换它一样。是的，我觉得这感觉有点像自然的延伸，但是说，让我拍一段视频，使用不是像我们看到的很多文本，我想，但我很好奇，你刚才说音频，那看起来很自然，但是，
I wonder like either like signaling to chat GPT or one of these for outputs, like hand motions, like, but basically like video, right? Like either make a scene like this or some description of what you want to happen. Like, Hey,
我很好奇，比如向 ChatGPT 或其中一个输出端发出信号，比如手势，比如，但基本上就像视频，对吧？比如制作一个这样的场景，或者对你想要发生的事情进行某种描述。比如，嘿，
I want you to make something this big, right? Like I'm holding my hands up. This is audio. It's a podcast. Size of a postcard, you know, I size of a postcard,
我想要你制作一个这么大的东西，对吧？就像我举起双手。这是音频。这是一个播客。明信片大小，你知道，我明信片大小，
you know, I, you know, make an image where something's like this and you're just talking to it and using hand gestures. And then it's able to sort of like accomplish the same sorts of things yeah actually with that in mind you another thing that i would like to see i expect to see in the future is partition decisions like here's a good example like a scrapbook so so imagine if you could say like here's a bunch
你知道，我，你知道，制作一张图像，其中某样东西是这样的，你只是在和它交谈并使用手势。然后它就能够完成同样的事情。是的，实际上考虑到这一点，你还想看到的一件事，我预计在未来会看到的是分区决策，比如这是一个很好的例子，比如剪贴簿。所以，想象一下，如果你能说，这是一堆
of photos i don't need you generate a photo or anything but i want you to lay out a scrapbook so that's a set of like very discreet decisions that like ladder up to a scrapbook but like it's not fluid like text or image you know um like things that like layouts floor plans another example you know things where yeah there was oh plans. That would be good. There's also that, oh, that's, that'd be good. I bet it'll happen. If you recall when the iPhones, there was that iMovie and there was that trend for people making trailers
照片，我不需要你生成照片或任何东西，但我想要你排版一本剪贴簿，所以这是一组非常离散的决策，它们层层递进形成一本剪贴簿，但它不像文本或图像那样流畅，你知道，嗯，比如布局、平面图之类的东西，另一个例子，你知道，是的，有哦，计划。那会很好。还有那个，哦，那会很好。我敢打赌它会发生。如果你还记得 iPhone 的时候，有那个 iMovie，当时人们制作预告片的趋势是
where like the beginning and then like input picture of yourself and then like, and they were having an adventure and like a little clip of, I feel like those kinds of things, ChachiB2 would be really good at. Some of the photo services try to do them, but they're always kind of hokey.
开头，然后输入你自己的照片，然后，他们正在进行冒险，还有一小段剪辑，我觉得这些事情，ChatGPT 会非常擅长。一些照片服务试图做这些，但它们总是有点老套。
They're like, hey, I had my, can you take all the pictures from my vacation and like make a highlight reel set to music in the style of Evel Knievel? And then it's like, you know, here's whatever, I don't know. Yeah, that'd be freaking cool. Also like if it could do vector images. So like, again, it's like partition based decisions. Like, can you compose, you know, circles and crescents and lines to make like a vector logo? That's really cool. That would be awesome.
它们就像，嘿，我有我的，你能把我假期里的所有照片拿出来，然后配上音乐，做成埃维尔·克尼维尔风格的精彩片段吗？然后就像，你知道，这是什么，我不知道。是的，那会非常酷。还有，如果它能做矢量图像。所以，同样，它就像基于分区的决策。比如，你能组合，你知道，圆圈、新月和线条来制作一个矢量标志吗？那真的很酷。那会很棒。
All right. Well, thank you, everyone, for listening in to another episode? Yeah, thanks, everybody. A lot of folks have emailed us and chatted to us in the Discord about ChatGPT. So this is for you all. And yeah, I thought this was a great time. Thanks again for sponsoring the show and being a patron if you're one of our patrons on Patreon.
好了。好吧，谢谢大家收听又一期节目？是的，谢谢大家。很多人给我们发了电子邮件，并在 Discord 上和我们聊了关于 ChatGPT 的事情。所以这是给你们所有人的。是的，我觉得这是一段很棒的时光。再次感谢赞助本节目，如果你是我们 Patreon 的赞助人之一，感谢你的支持。
We sent out the t-shirts from the holiday episode. Folks were really excited to get those shirts. So I'm glad you all like that. Congratulations to our t-shirts from the holiday episode folks were really excited to uh to get those shirts so i'm glad y'all like that um congratulations to our t-shirt winners this year and uh we'll catch y'all in a couple weeks music by eric barn dollar Music by Eric Barndollar Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license.
我们寄出了节日特辑的 T 恤。大家对收到那些 T 恤感到非常兴奋。所以我很高兴你们都喜欢。祝贺我们今年的 T 恤获奖者，我们几周后再见。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。
You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。